die
Ich bin gerade aufgestanden vor irgendwie 20 Minuten oder so, aber nämlich überhaupt
funktioniert alles.
Ich habe jetzt nämlich mein Audiointerface umgestöpselt, ich hoffe OBS hat sich nicht
verschluckt.
Aber ich denke geht alles, oder?
Jo, geht alles exquisite.
Mal kurz gucken ob die Lautstärke stimmt, weil es ist hier glaube ich nicht richtig.
Moin Michael 50 Trillionen Billiarden, naja das ist richtig, oh dann weiß ich auch nicht.
So, bisschen leiser machen.
Ah jetzt ist hier, die Hacker-Mans sind am Start, ich seh's.
Muss euch mal was geiles erzählen von der Arbeit, ich bin jetzt ja gerade ein bisschen
weniger am Video machen und weniger ein bisschen am Streamen, weil ich muss mich erstmal wieder
an 4 Tage arbeiten die Woche gewöhnen, ich weiß für viele First World Problems, weil
sie 5 Tage die Woche arbeiten mussten, aber ich muss mich da erstmal wieder dran gewöhnen,
naja, muss ich was lustiges erzählen.
Was soll ich erzählen, das passt in den Chat, sorry, mich hat am Freitag Mittag irgendwann,
oder was Donnerstag, ist auch egal wann das gewesen ist, ich glaube Freitag Mittag war
das noch, hat mich mein Chef angerufen und hat gemeint, hier Max, wir haben hier irgendwie,
er hat hier irgendwie einen von seinen Management Kollegen oder sowas, ne nicht so von seinen
Management Kollegen, Entwickler und ob ich dem Entwickler, und jetzt kommt's Leute, haltet
euch fest, haltet euch fest, ob ich dem Entwickler mal zeigen könnte, wie man Dateien unter Linux
löscht und hab ich erstmal gemacht, ich dachte da kommt noch was, ich dachte das ist jetzt
quasi der, ich dachte das ist quasi der Aufhänger für irgendwas größeres, ja, hab ich kurz
gewartet und hab gedacht, hm, kommt nix mehr, mein Mikrofon war übrigens auch kaputt,
muss ich bloß da mit dem Handy zurück rufen, so und dann hab ich gesagt, ja klar, kein
Problem und jetzt kommt der Hammer, da meinte der Entwickler, ja, da machen wir nächste
Woche doch mal einen Termin dafür, ja okay, lad einfach ein, mein Kalender ist aktuell
und dann hat er allen Ernstes, jetzt kommt's einen, eine Stunde Termin eingetragen, also
es lässt mich mal wieder an der Fähigkeit unserer Entwickler zweifeln, was soll ich
dem denn da krasses zeigen, rm-rf, was, was, was du willst, was soll ich dem großartig
zeigen, was länger als fünf Minuten dauert, man weiß es nicht, man weiß es nicht, richtig
Monarchs, ja, das hab ich mir auch gedacht, da hat man Google geguckt, aber okay, ich
mein, ich hab da keinen Schmerzen mit, ich zeig ihm das auch, aber, hm, irgendwelches
Permission-Gedöns, hm, ich mein, ey, diese Vermutung ist gar nicht mal so weit hergeholt,
wisst ihr was sein kann, dass das eigentlich ein riesen Chebat ist, dass der Entwickler
weiß, wie man löscht, aber er hat keine Rechte dafür und er möchte mir jetzt quasi
zeigen, ja, Max, mach das doch mal als mein User und dann festzustellen, oh, das geht
ja gar nicht, wir haben ja keine Rechte, ja, was machen wir denn da jetzt, das könnte
sein, dass das so ein Chebat ist in der Richtung, dass ich dann sag, ja, Moment, ich geb dir
die Rechte oder so, das, das könnte, das könnte echt sein, die sind ja nicht, ich,
ich glaub zwar, die sind blöd, aber die sind ja eigentlich gar nicht blöd, das ist bestimmt,
das ist bestimmt, Trick 17, der Tom Lachser, zwei Monate, kennt noch jemand, Ben Lachser,
ne, wie hieß der, ist der Ben Lachser, der, der, der Tierernährungsexperte und Teppich-Zuschneide-Experte
oder was nicht alles gab, Ben, Ben Lachser, gibt's ja nicht mal, gibt's ja nicht mal,
der hat irgendwie sein Channel verkauft oder so, keine Ahnung, das Känguru hat sein Weltverschönerungsexperte,
ja, das war der Anfang von Ende, vom Ende dieser Channel, wisst ihr, dass, dass ich
Katja Grazavice zum ersten Mal bei ihm auf diesem Channel gesehen hab und wer hätte
damals ahnen können, ähm, was da noch so kommt, tja, wir sind agil, wir machen erstmal
zwei Stunden Stand-Up, wo man sich nicht hinsetzen darf, ja, bestimmt, bestimmt, bestimmt,
damals sah es ja noch halbwegs normal aus, ja, aber der hat irgendwie sein Channel verkauft
und jetzt, weiß ich nicht, oh, die Katze ist an der Tür, Sekunde, Leute, Chico, was ist
denn? Sekunde, ja, die will mit mir Action machen im Wohnzimmer, glaub ich, die war nämlich
an der Tür und ist dann losgeflitzt Richtung Wohnzimmer, aber da geh ich jetzt nicht mit,
entweder hätte sie reinkommen sollen oder nicht, Pech, Pech gehabt, Chico, ja, so, ach
ja, gucken wir uns mal ein paar Sachen an, wie sonst so irgendwas Spannendes passiert
so die letzten Tage, ich überleg gerade, fällt jetzt nichts ein, ist irgendwas passiert?
Hab ich irgendwas, irgendwas verpasst? Ach, glaub ich, die Woche nicht so viel Spannendes,
oder? Wir haben 69 Zuschauer, ne, jetzt sind schon wieder mehr, wir hatten kurzzeit 69
Zuschauer, Battlefield ist immer noch Müll, ja, das ist ja nichts Neues, ach ja, wo wir
gerade dabei sind, sehr, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz aktualisieren, ähm, da haben wir
es doch noch auf, bäm, bäm, oh, es wird ja immer besser, oh, Battlefield ist wieder
über die 10.000 Spieler Marke, Leute, ja, gut, es ist Wochenende, letzte Woche haben
wir es nämlich geschafft, unter 9.000, unter 9.000, muss man sich mal vorstellen, von 100.000,
ich meine, okay, es ist nur Steam, aber Origin und äh, die Konsolen haben garantiert den
ähnlichen Trend, so, und ein Alltime Low haben wir wahrscheinlich auch für New World, okay,
New World haben wir wirklich einen Allzeit, Allzeit Low, ruf das mal an, 86k, hast du nicht
auf Twitter das gepostet mit den 5 Euro, ja, aber, das ist ja nur halb richtig, das war
ein Druckfehler, das habe ich einfach mal weggelassen zu erwähnen, das hier war, glaub
ich, also, das Original, das Original Bild, war, glaub ich, nur ein Druckfehler mit 4.99,
das habe ich, das habe ich aber nicht erwähnt, oh, Jesus trendet, Jesus, Putin und Gottschalk
trendet, na, da kann ja nichts mehr schief gehen heutzutage, warum trendet Jesus eigentlich,
ist heute irgendwas, bei Jesus muss ich immer denken an, der sagt da Jesus, wer das nicht
weiß, der sagt da Jesus, jetzt, das soll Jesus heißen, weil der Host der Talkshow heißt
Jesus mit Vorname, gut, ich meine, Spanier, der heißt Jesus oder so, ich, ich gucke mir
keine, ich gucke mir keine Twitter Trends in Deutschland an, was der Tennis, Tennis Dude
ist, endlich, endgültig aus Australien ausgeht, das habe ich nur so am Rande mitgekriegt, dass
irgendwie erst Gericht gesagt hat, ja geht, dann hat irgendwie der oberste, was weiß ich,
Minister Typ in Australien gesagt, geht nicht und jetzt hat irgendwie nochmal ein Gericht
gesagt, geht nicht oder irgendwie sowas, das sind Trends für mich, ja Trends für mich
sind schwierig, ich mache hier auf Twitter nichts auf, außer meinen eigenen Channel,
also wenn Jesus der Trend für mich ist, dann stimmt, also es ist eigentlich gut, wenn Twitter
denkt, dass Jesus der richtige Trend für mich ist, weil dann hat Twitter absolut keine
Ahnung, was sie mir präsentieren sollen, weil ich glaube, es gibt kaum etwas, was mich
weniger interessiert als irgendwelche religiösen Sachen, Tesla In-App Kauf, der teuerste In-App
Kauf, 22, oh nee, keine 22 Minuten, keine 22 Minuten wird zum Einstieg, nope, ich bin
ein Christlich, an Weihnachten, ja, da haben wir teilweise Weihnachtsmusik laufen, ultrakristlich,
viel christlicher geht es eigentlich gar nicht, also ich meine, meine Weihnachtstreams sind
ja wohl das Christliche, was es so gibt, Moin, kannst du einen guten Bürostuhl fürs Homeoffice
empfehlen, ja und nein, ich kann den empfehlen, den ich habe, aber nein, den würde ich keinem
empfehlen, weil der eigentlich preisleistungsmäßig, tja, busy zu teuer ist, dementsprechend kann
ich dir keinen, also ich zeig dir einfach mal welchen ich habe, aber wie gesagt jetzt
nicht irgendwie Instant-Kauf-Empfehlung oder sowas, ich habe den hier, Mister 24, den gibt
es mit verschiedenen Kopfstützen, den gibt es auch mit, also du kannst die Sitzfläche
kannst du einstellen, du kannst die Höhe einstellen, du kannst die Arme links, rechts,
vorne, hinten einstellen, die Höhe einstellen, wie sehr die Rückenlehne hin und zurück geht,
du kannst hier oben rein und raus, also du kannst quasi alles mögliche einstellen und
ich finde den Stuhl echt extrem nice, das einzige Problem an diesem Stuhl ist, dass
der etwas zu teuer ist, um ihn sich für einen Heimbereich einfach mal so zu kaufen, deswegen
würde ich das auch nicht empfehlen, ansonsten kann ich dir leider nichts, kann ich dir leider
nichts empfehlen, weil den Stuhl habe ich jetzt seit 8 Jahren oder so und ich will auch
nichts anderes mehr und er ist immer noch super und das schöne ist, wenn ich es mal wirklich
komplett durchgesetzt haben sollte, könnte ich mir auch immer noch einen Ersatzteil kaufen,
gibt es ja dafür, immerhin streamt er ja auch jeden Sonntag zur Gottesdienstzeit, ach
stimmt, stimmt ist jetzt ja, jetzt kommen jetzt müssen ja eigentlich die Schafe in
die Kirche, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, ja, ja, nö habe ich nix, ich habe mal angefangen,
ich weiß nicht, war das paperless oder so, ich habe mal mit irgendeinem GitHub Projekt
angefangen das zu verwenden und bin dann relativ schnell zu dem Schluss gekommen, ich bin dazu
faul für alles einzuscannen, ich habe keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, wie gesagt an Stühlen
hatte ich bisher nur, also die ich mir selbst für den PC so gekauft habe, hatte ich bisher
nur ein DX Racer, der war richtig kacke, also hier seit dem Umzug, wobei, habe ich den
seit dem, Leute ich habe den, doch ich habe den ziemlich genau acht Jahren, 2013 bin
ich umgezogen, also seit dem Umzug, ich hatte einen DX Racer, der war richtig Müll, da
ist es, die Armlehne ist aus dem Rahmen rausgebrochen, wahrscheinlich war es nicht richtig geschweißt
unten zusammen, richtiger Müll nach einem Jahr oder so, das war kompletter Crap und
dann habe ich mir den hier gekauft und seitdem, seit 2014 oder so habe ich hier diesen, diesen
Sedus Mr.24 Stuhl am Starten, der ist wirklich top, wie viele Tage hast du eigentlich momentan
Homeoffice, noch jeden Tag, aktuell noch jeden Tag, bei uns auf der Arbeit gibt es Stühle
von Svensto, klingt wie irgendwie so ein schwedisches Bonbon oder sowas, ich muss übrigens gleich
ein paar Bonbons futtern, sonst wird mein Hals wieder so trocken, ich muss trinken,
trinken und Bonbons lutschen während dem Stream ab und zu mal, sonst merke ich es im
Hals, wenn ich so viel und so lange schwätze, ja übrigens der Grund, ich sage euch mal jetzt
wie es ist, der Grund ist nicht nur, dass ich eben wieder arbeiten muss, dass ich so
wenig gestreamt habe und Videos mache, ich bin auch wieder ein bisschen Oldschool MMO
Grind hängen geblieben, komplett, komplett sinnlos, auf irgendeinem FreeShot, der eh
wahrscheinlich im Halten Jahr abgeschaltet wird, also eigentlich richtig hängen geblieben,
was willst du machen?
Quatsch, nicht New World, ich spiele wieder Dark Edge of Camelot auf einem FreeShot, auf
einem fast PvP Only FreeShot, also PvR Only FreeShot, wo es kaum PvE gibt und zerge da
so durch die Gegend und zerge alles um oder einfach mal in einem Geschäft gehen direkt,
das ist tatsächlich auch eine gute Idee, ich weiß bloß nicht wie das aktuell in Corona
Zeiten aussieht, ja aber aktuell habe ich noch 4 Tage Home Office und es wird auch erstmal
solange die Pflicht weiter besteht so bleiben und wenn diese, also wenn die wirklich auf
die Idee kommen sollen, ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal jetzt gesagt, wenn die wirklich
auf die Idee kommen sollen, wir sollen wieder irgendwie zum größten Teil nach Frankfurt
oder maximal 2 Tage Home Office oder sowas, dann werde ich meine Arbeitszeit so weit verkürzen,
dass ich nur einen Tag nach Frankfurt muss, einen Tag nach Frankfurt ist ja schon genug,
Stress mit der Bahn, ich meine die Leute haben auf Twitter geschrieben, sie können eher
die Uhr stellen nach meinem Geflame über die Bahn Dienstag morgens als für die Bahn
selbst, das sagt ja wohl schon einiges, Kacipas, ja Bürostühle sind absolut in Ordnung, die
sind ja dafür gemacht, dass man drauf sitzt, ich persönlich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich
halte von Gaming Stühlen seit ich diesen, also eigentlich schon vorher nicht, aber ich
wollte es mit diesem, ich wollte es halt mit der DX Racer Geschichte mal ausprobieren,
ich halte von Gaming Stühlen nichts und ich sehe auch den Sinn von Gaming Stühlen nicht,
wenn man doch einfach einen Bürostuhl nehmen kann, wenn man doch einfach einen Bürostuhl
nehmen kann, was ist der Vorteil von einem Gaming Stuhl, zu Black Death als soll ja auch
eins, ernsthaft, was willst du da, Spin-offen, How-To von einer Million zu keinen Abonnenten
oder Spieler zahlen, PoE, PoE habe ich jetzt eine Weile nicht mehr angefasst, PoE ist
für mich immer nur so ein Game, wenn ich gar nichts anderes zu tun habe, weder irgendwelche
privaten Progas-Projekte noch sonderlich viel Bock auf Videos und Streamen habe und sonst
was und auch sonst kein anderes Game habe, dann spiele ich PoE, PoE gucke ich mir wahrscheinlich
wieder an, wenn PoE 2 rauskommt, ansonsten nur wenn die anderen Sachen eintreten dafür.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich gesponsert oder?
Sekunde Leute, ich muss mal was mit der Katze machen, die macht krach draußen im Flur.
Mhh...
Jetzt bin ich raus, jetzt bin ich rausgekommen, sie ist wieder weggeflitzt, die will Action
machen gerade, aber ich hab jetzt keine Zeit, dabei haben wir heute morgen schon Action
gemacht.
Die Stühle von Porsche, ich wusste gar nicht, dass die Stühle haben.
Digibaitet mich ja, sozusagen.
Moin Max, Zeit fürs Bonbon, ich merk's schon.
Moin Max, hast du ein paar Tipps für Sicherheitssoftware für den Heimrechner?
Ach übrigens Leute, der Schwamm ist angekommen, ich hab mir doch einen Schwamm gekauft, um
mir einen Pop-Schutz für meinen Headset zu bauen, der besser ist als der Pop-Schutz,
der dabei ist.
Ich hab Big Brain Time gemacht, ich hab mir nicht einfach nur einen Schwamm geholt, ich
hab mir einen Car Wash Sponge geholt.
Oder sowas, ne.
Car Wash Schwamm, ich weiß nicht wie es auf Englisch heißt, heißt das nicht Sponge?
Sowas hier hab ich mir geholt, in der Richtung, so einen richtig, richtig fetten, mega Schwamm
und da schneiden wir einen Pop-Schutz raus für meinen Headset und dann gucken wir, ob
es weniger poppt.
Massive Schwamm.
Moin Max, hast du ein paar Tipps für Sicherheitssoftware für den Heimrechner?
Die Sicherheitssoftware soll gegen die gängigen Schadsoftware, oder Schadware, wie das Semper-Video
sagen würde.
Oh, ich kann das nicht so schön betonen, wie sagt er das immer?
Schadware, ich kann das nicht sehen.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Also die Sicherheitssoftware soll gegen die gängigen Schadsoftware, die so im Umlauf
ist, schützen.
Du hast mal wieder das Windows Defender, ja, Windows Defender reicht immer noch, reicht
immer noch, Windows Defender ist das einzige, was man braucht.
Ach ja, da fällt mir doch noch ein, was jetzt rausgekommen ist, Avira, das war ja mal eine
Zeit lang voll angesagt, Avira hat jetzt Krypto-Miners im Anti-Viren-Scanner.
Ja, Norton auch, Norton auch, Avira auch.
Auf dem PC, den ich als Vorschau verwende, habe ich das auch noch drauf, der PC ist aber
halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, acht Jahre alt, damals habe ich es halt noch installiert,
ich habe jetzt auch ein Krypto-Miner drauf bei mir auf dem Vorschau-PC, aber das Gute
bei Avira ist, dass das standardmäßig aus ist.
Aber wisst ihr, das bestärkt wieder einen Punkt, was ich auch schon seit Jahren sage,
das Anti-Virus-Software von den Praktiken her und von dem, was sie so machen halt einfach,
gar nicht so weit weg ist von dem, vor was sie eigentlich beschützen wollen.
Das war in der Vergangenheit schon öfters mal zu sehen, mit ultra-aufdringlicher Werbung,
was fast schon Scareware-mäßig war, mit wir haben sie jetzt geploggt von 250 Gefahren,
kaufen sie jetzt die Premium-Version und jetzt wird es immer offensichtlicher.
Zumal das Ding komplett Root-Rechte und, oder was heißt Root, wie heißt es unter Windows,
Root-Rechte hat.
Sollte ich mal bei mir kurz gucken auf dem zweiten Rechner, ob Krypto-Mining an ist.
Ich habe wohl noch nicht das Neue, das sieht bei mir ganz anders aus.
Ich habe den Button hier oben über dem Handy noch nicht, aber es ist eigentlich schon ziemlich
hart, oder?
Und vor allem die große Frage ist, was ist der Sinn von einem Krypto-Miner in einer Anti-Viren-Software?
Ich meine, wir können uns alle das beantworten.
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was es sein könnte?
Es ist wie immer Stonks, was sonst?
Weil es wahrscheinlich so sein wird, auch bei Avira, dass wenn du mit Avira Krypto meinst
und im Prinzip eh schon Minus machst, weil es auf der CPU in der Regel überhaupt nicht
rentabel ist, aber egal, dann kriegst du noch nicht mal deine gemeinten Coins, sondern du
kriegst wahrscheinlich nur irgendwie 80% und 20% bei Held Avira.
Das ist einzig und allein Geld machen für Avira.
Das ist ja fast schon Botnetz-Qualitäten hier.
Gut, zum Glück ist es standardmäßig aus, aber trotzdem.
Also sollte das standardmäßig eingeschaltet sein, muss man ehrlich sagen, dann ist ja
wirklich kein Unterschied mehr zwischen irgendeinem Botnetz- und Anti-Viren-Software.
Naja, wird mal Zeit den Gramm runterzuschmeißen von meinem zweiten Rechner.
Ich will mir ein System programmieren, dass meine Dart-Scheibe mit Mittels Bilderkennung
automatisch mitzähle.
Oh, das ist eine coole Idee.
Das dürfte glaube ich sogar verhältnismäßig einfach sein, weil, und das ist nur verhältnismäßig
einfach, wenn meine Vermutung stimmt, weil ich wetten könnte, dass es dafür schon fertig
trainierte AI-Geschichten gibt, die man verwenden kann.
Gucken wir mal, Github, Dart, AI, Image, achso Dart, tja, Dart ist ja auch eine Programmiersprache,
was heißt ein Dart-Scheibe auf Englisch, Dart-Scheibe-Englisch, was heißt denn das, Dart-Board, ok, wisst
ihr, Automatic Scoring System, ja, ok, also wenn man da so schnell was findet, gibt es
da sicherlich noch mehr und auch sicherlich deutlich bessere als ein fünf Jahre altes
Projekt.
Dann stelle ich mir das relativ einfach vor und du hast wahrscheinlich einen Vorteil,
wenn du es mit dem Raspberry Pi und der Raspberry Pi Cam machst, weil du dann das alles auf
einer Kiste laufen lassen kannst.
Du nimmst einen Raspberry Pi, ich würde, ich weiß nicht, ob ein Zero ausreicht, der
neue Zero, der, äh, der neue Zero sollte auf jeden Fall reichen, der ist also ungefähr
so stark wie ein Raspberry Pi 3, nimmst einen Zero 2, machst eine Kamera dran, ja gut, den
Vierer kannst du auch nehmen, wobei halt ein Zero einfacher ist an die Wand zu hängen.
Was ist ein Raspberry Pi, das ist ein kleiner Computer, wo Linux drauf läuft, gibt es in
verschiedenen Formfaktoren, es gibt den ganz kleinen und es gibt halt den normal großen,
die sind aber alle relativ klein, das ist im Prinzip ein Computer, wo Linux drauf läuft,
das ist gar nicht so ein großer Unterschied zu einem Desktoprechner, natürlich von der
Leistung her schon, das ist andere Architektur drunter, also anderes Instructionset und alles
für die CPU, aber das muss dich als Anwender nicht interessieren.
Ist halt beliebt, weil klein, relativ günstig und Stromsparend.
Ja, aber das ist eine super Geschichte dafür, ich würde einfach mal gucken, was für Gitterprojekte
gibt und wahrscheinlich gibt es fix und fertige Gitterprojekte, wo du einfach nur irgendwas
auf dein Raspberry Pi ziehst, ähm, startest und die Kamera passend positionierst, also
den Raspberry Pi mit Kamerapassen positionierst, der Vorteil von einem Pi Zero wäre natürlich
auch, weil es da ein Kameracase gibt, es gibt ein fertiges Case, das ist sogar dabei bei
so einem Starterset, da hast du halt die Kamera mit drin, da kannst du dieses Ding, da machst
du hinten einfach zwei, drei Klebestreifen, Powerstrips oder so drauf und pappst gegenüber
an die Wand und dann hast du deine Datscheibe gefilmt.
Ja, aber aus diesem einzigen Grund dürfte es relativ einfach sein, weil eben schon fertige
Projekte existieren, die das machen.
Ja, Offside-Backups, wenn du wirklich sicher sein willst, dass dein Zeug auch im Falle
eines Haus-Einstürzes oder Brandes oder Überschwemmungen noch da ist, musst du Offside-Backups machen,
wenn du das in Erwägung ziehst, also wenn du dich dagegen sichern möchtest, wenn du
denkst, es ist so wahrscheinlich, dass es sich lohnt, dagegen zu sichern, dann musst
du Offside-Backups machen und am besten natürlich noch, das schreibt der Chat ja auch, am besten
natürlich noch, wenn dann deine Daten irgendwo am anderen Ende der Welt liegen, aber auf
der anderen Seite, wenn du es bei einem Cloud-Anbieter machst, da sorgen die in der Regel schon
dafür, dass das sinnvoll gespeichert ist, muss ja nicht gerade Dropbox sein.
Ja, Offside-Backups, das ist das Einzige, was du machen kannst.
Das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, ja, ja mittlerweile finde ich, ist das relativ offensichtlich,
wenn die schon mit Krypto-Miner in Anti-Viren-Software anfangen, sehe ich da keinen Unterschied
mehr.
Ja, der Witz ist, es gibt ja genug Malware, die so tut, als wären sie Anti-Virus und was
ist jetzt noch der Unterschied zwischen Malware, die tut, als wären sie Anti-Virus und einer
richtigen Anti-Viren-Software, die Malware-Sachen mitbringt, man weiß es nicht, ne?
Hattest du auch mal so ein Ticket, Minecraft crashes, when I go to the toilet, nö, frag
mich, wo ByteStrikes die Dinger immer ausbuddelt hier, Minecraft crashes, when I go to the
toilet, wenn er halt so Dinge wurscht legt, dass das irgendwie sein Rechner beeinflusst,
dann, ne, weiß ich auch nicht.
ne, weiß ich auch nicht, nö, frag mich, wo ByteStrikes die Dinger immer ausbuddelt
hier, WordPress.
Da bietet sich ja ein Raspberry Pi auch durchaus für an.
Ich habe es damals mit echter Hardware gemacht.
Also ich habe ein Layer 2 VPN für meine Abschlussprüfung gebaut.
Natürlich habe ich es nicht... Also man muss ja bei der IHK das immer so verkaufen,
dass das nach Stonks und Business klingt. Wenn du der IHK verkaufst,
ich baue ein VPN zwischen A und B oder ich baue ein OpenVPN zwischen A und B oder an Wire...
Frag ich hab vergessen wie es heißt. Wie heißt das neue super angesachte VPN? Wire? Wirechamp?
Wireguard? Wireguard, genau. Jetzt muss ich wieder eingeben. Chat weiß auch Wireguard.
Wenn du sagst, ich baue ein Wireguard VPN zwischen A und B, dann ist das kein gutes Abschlussprojekt.
Du musst schreiben, Evaluierung einer VPN Lösung zum Verbinden zweier Standorte auf Layer 2 oder
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Weil Evaluierung, da steht die IHK drauf, da machen die richtig
Postchamp. Sobald sie diesen Antrag lesen, Postchampen die richtig, weil sie denken,
oh Eval, da geht ihnen voll einer drauf ab bei der IHK, wenn die Evaluierung lesen.
Und dann musst du eine Produktauswahl Tabelle machen oder Verprobung, das ist auch so ein
grausames Wort. Dann machst du eine Tabelle mit Produktauswahl, legst dir verschiedene Punkte
aus, auf was du Wert legst und dann machst du eine Produktauswahl, wo du den verschiedenen
VPN-Produkten, die es gibt, Punkte gibst und deine VPN-Lösung, mit der du das bauen willst,
gewinnt natürlich dann rein zufällig in deiner Produktauswahl und dann baust du einen VPN auf.
Und das kannst du ja auch ohne Probleme mit Raspberry Pi zu Raspberry Pi machen. Warum nicht?
Ist sogar relativ günstig. Du musst da von Raspberry Pi in beide Standorte stellen.
Kannst du einfach sagen Standort, ich habe es genannt Standort-Kopplung habe ich es genannt,
genau Standort-Kopplung hieß das bei mir im Ablussprojekt. Ich kriege es nicht mal genau
zusammen Standort-Kopplung. Irgendwas in der Richtung, aber ja, das kannst du mit,
kannst du einen VPN bauen mit zwei Raspberry Pies. Aber ansonsten gibt es natürlich noch
jede Menge andere Sachen, aber da fällt mir gerade nichts ein. Es sei denn im Chat fällt
noch was ein. Leona Bomber, Dankeschön für den Sub. Muss mal kurz gucken, ich habe schon
mehr die Hälfte vergessen, die subscribt haben. Wende, ne gefolgt, aber auch hier Follow Pog.
Leona Bomber, Danke für den Sub. Tom Laksa auch hier am Start. Okay,
habe ich zum Glück nicht so viel übersehen. Niemand lässt auf dem Raspberry Pi Windows laufen.
Da funktioniert die Hälfte ja nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, geht Netzwerk mittlerweile unter
Windows auf dem Raspberry Pi? Mal ganz nachher auf dem 3er kannst du Windows und nicht mal
gescheit booten sein, du hast eine halbe Stunde Zeit, da läuft Linux drauf. Alles andere ist
experimenteller Blödsinn. Ja, irgendwelche Grafana Monitoring Geschichten kannst du natürlich
auch machen, aber du musst halt immer dran denken bei der IHR-AK Abschlussprüfung. Du
darfst es nicht verkaufen als ich installiere Grafana und klicke drei Grafen an. Du musst
es als irgendwie Business Enterprise Lösung verkaufen. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht,
dass es super komplex sein muss, sondern du musst was auswählen, du musst was evaluieren,
du musst irgendwie was entscheiden, planen, weil die IHR-AK ist ja immer noch der Meinung,
du bist zur Hälfte Kaufmann als Fachinformatiker. Passt das denn mit den Stunden klar? Ganz
davon abgesehen die Stunden in der Abschlussprüfung faked doch eh jeder hin, dass es passt.
Ist das so? Windows Arm Edition. Als letztes Mal wo ich geguckt habe, Windows auf dem Raspberry
Pi zu sehen war das ein riesen Akt und Netzwerk und Bluetooth und so Zeug gingen gar nicht.
So, moin Eax. ET System Kaufmann, was haben sie jetzt? Haben sie? Weiß ich nicht. Ich
weiß nur, dass die IHR-K immer sagt Fachinformatiker als halber Kaufmann. Warum sagt die IHR-K
das? Weil die IHR-K nur Kaufmänner ausbilden darf. Ist übrigens auch witzig, ne? Gerade
mal zur Bezugnehmend auf mein letztes Video, was ich gemacht habe. Nein, ich sehe immer
noch nicht aus wie der Friseur. Das letzte Video, was ich gemacht habe zum Thema Fachkräftemangel,
was ich da auch lustig fand, ist ein Punkt, den ich ganz vergessen habe oder nicht genug
angesprochen habe, ist, dass viele Unternehmen auch sagen, sie wollen keine Azubis mehr haben
und sich dann beschweren, wenn sie keine Leute mehr finden. Das ist mir erst im Nachhinein
auch so richtig aufgefallen, dass ich dazu gar nichts gesagt habe, weil dort, wo ich
arbeite, ist es ganz genauso. Die haben gesagt, sie wollen jetzt nicht mehr ausbilden, suchen
aber händeringend nach IT-Leuten. Du bist wahrscheinlich auch halber Kaufmann. Köche,
Köche. Oh, ich weiß nicht, was ich angeklickt habe, aber irgendwas, was ich nicht anklicken
sollte. Kann ich nichts zu sagen, aber nachdem wir drei Leute haben, die so einen Ausbildungzettel
haben oder mal gemacht haben, kann ich mir das nicht so schwer vorstellen. Was war denn
das? Der Clip ist auch äußerst unglücklich. Ich wusste ja schon, was passiert. Was ich
nicht wusste, ist, dass er über die Windows-Mounts mit drüber geht. Der hat halt einfach mein
Windows mitgelöscht. Also merke, Sudo-ORM ist keine gute Idee in WSL, weil es löscht
auch dein Windows-Shit mit. Der Chet fand es natürlich supergeil. Das klicken wir jetzt
nicht an, Chet. Nein, wer weiß. Habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass vor nicht allzu langer Zeit drei koreanische
Cosplayerinnen gebannt wurden auf Twitch, weil sie sich umgezogen haben und die eine
nicht richtig offscreen war? Tja, verkackt würde ich mal sagen. So, also YouTube, was
gucken wir uns denn heute an? 22 Reasons? Nein, Battlefield Geflame gucke ich mir heute nicht
an. Wir lassen uns jebaiten. Levelcap jebait. Der Levelcap jebait. Levelcap jebait. Wisst
ihr, warum die sich alle immer für jeden Scheiß entschuldigen? Ich sage euch jetzt
mal warum. Weil Entschuldigen nix kostet. Entschuldigen ist das billigste und einfachste,
was du machen kannst. Du entschuldigst dich einfach random für jeden Scheiß, wo sich
irgendeiner dran offendet haben könnte. Kostet dich nix. Du kannst immer noch sagen, ja gut,
wir haben es eingesehen. Wir haben uns ja entschuldigt. Keine Ahnung. Da kann ich dir wirklich nix
zu sagen. Ich habe noch keine Android App gemacht. iOS App auch noch nicht. Stimmt,
ich habe seit letztem Sonntag nicht gestreamt. Auf Steam? Ja Kirby ist ja gut, Alter. Oha,
sehr gut. Exzellent. Sachen gibts. Sehr schön, da kann ich es vielleicht jetzt auch endlich
spielen. Was braucht man mindestens? Ahja, easy. Easy, easy. Ok, gucken wir lassen uns
vor LevelCapture beenden. Lautstärke muss passen, oder? Lautstärke muss eigentlich ziemlich
gut sein. Das ist natürlich das, was die Leute gerade, das wollen die Leute haben.
So schlecht. Das ist genau das, was die Leute haben wollen. Battlefield 2042, sieben PC.
Auf dem wahrscheinlich Battlefield 2042 nicht mehr gescheit läuft.
We teamed up with LevelCapture. Es ist ja noch nicht mal als hätte LevelCapture da irgendwas
damit zu tun gehabt. Die haben einfach gesagt, LevelCapture, wie sieht es aus? Mal ein Sponsoring
Video. Und er hat gesagt, yep, wenn es ordentlich Kohle gibt, es gab ordentlich Kohle und gut,
er hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn irgendwelche Beauty-
YouTuber irgendwie Schminke zeigen oder so. Dann da steht irgendwie Powered By oder irgendwie
in Kooperation mit. Oder wenn Kick mit Heidi Klum Werbung macht, so als hätte die da mit
Klamotten designt oder so. Das ist Schwachsinn. Steht einfach der Name drauf. Und was meint
ihr, wie viele da mitgemacht haben? Mehr als fünf? Na natürlich, ganz ehrlich, ich würde
da auch mitmachen, weil aktuell PC-Hardware würde ich auch nehmen in 2042er Optik. Meinen
ihr, nicht wegen der 2042 Optik, sondern einfach weil aktueller Hardware so schwer zu bekommen
ist? Wisst ihr, was ich feiern würde, wenn der Typ, der das gewinnt, ein Video zu macht,
das quasi zu, ich weiß nicht, wie man das auf Englisch sagen würde, den PC quasi von
Battlefield 2042-Look zurückzubauen in normalen Look und dann zu sagen, ja, ich freue mich,
dass ich neue Hardware bekommen habe. Okay, okay, okay, okay, ist gut, genug, genug,
sei laut jetzt. Genug. Ja, auf jetzt. Haben wir's. Wir haben es. Wir haben es. Wir haben
es. Okay, jetzt. Die Musik ist ganz schön laut bei Levelcap immer, oder? Ach, jetzt
auch schon. Jetzt auch schon. Das ist ja fast schon Battlefield-würdig. Die haben es nach
drei Monaten nach Release jetzt auch mal offensichtlich gesagt, dass das Spiel Probleme hat. Was?
Nein, da wären wir ja nie drauf gekommen. Ja, so ein dummes Geschwätze. So alter, da
kriege ich Anfälle, wenn ich das lese. So ein dummes Geschwätze. Das Game ist ein Drittel
durch seine Lebenszeit durch. Das nächste Call of Duty soll ja angeblich vorgezogen
werden. Das kommt dann irgendwann im Oktober. Das Spiel hat ein Drittel seiner Lebenszeit
hinter sich und jetzt sagen sie Ja, wir haben euch gehört und Ja, wir machen da was dran.
So ein Schwachsinn. Das wussten die von Anfang an. Das ist einfach nur Big Stonks Marketing
Move jetzt, um die Leute noch ein bisschen länger bei der Stange zu halten. Nicht wirklich,
weil man vorhat da was zu machen. Also doch mal sagen wir so, wenn es um Warzone geht,
natürlich. Bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher. Geht es um Warzone? Wenn es um Warzone geht,
was anderes, weil Warzone ist das Ding, was massiv Kohle macht bei denen. Gucken wir mal.
Wir werden Bug-Fixationen und Angelegenheiten sobald es möglich ist. Sie sagen, dass die
Community-Feedback kritisch für den Entwicklungsprozess ist. Ja, ja, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Ja, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Niejemand mag die neue Map habe
ich das Gefühl, ich spiele ja Warzone nicht mehr aktiv aber ich schaue ab und zu auf Twitch
rein und die Leute sind eigentlich nur am Abgehen.
Weitermal – wusste ihr, dass Modern Warfare irgendwie seit einem halben Jahr und noch
richtig spielbar ist durch Updates. Interessiert doch keiner. Das ist ein zwei Jahre altes Call of Duty hookers.
Was wir immer noch für vollpreis verkaufen.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Das ist niemand von denen hat irgendwie vor da was dran zu ändern. Das ist einfach nur, ich weiß gar nicht. Ich
sagte jedes mal das gleiche zu. Und die Leute sind immer noch ganz scharf drauf so nach dem Motto
Oh sie haben eingesehen, dass sie schlecht, dass sie das schlecht gemacht haben. Oh ja jetzt wird das bestimmt besser. Ja ganz sicher, ganz sicher.
Oh Hazard Zone. Hat eigentlich jemand von euch Hazard Zone länger als fünf Minuten gespielt?
Ich weiß jetzt kommen die Leute im Chat, ja sechs Minuten.
Moment, jetzt habe ich es nicht verstanden. Was wird in die Portal Rotation?
Ach ja, jetzt kommt Rush wieder zurück, nachdem sie festgestellt haben, dass alles andere nicht spielbar ist in dem Game. Ja super clever.
Das ist ja, so sieht das aus, wenn man auf die Community hört.
Rush ist das einzige was man spielen kann in dem Spiel und Rush ist immer sonderlich gut.
Ja, das sagt schon, ohne Scheiße, das sagt alles über dieses Game. Wenn ein Half-Est, kann man das überhaupt so sagen?
Egal, Englisch, FTW, ein billig implementierter Rush Modus mit schlecht platzierten M-Coms auf schlecht für Rush geeigneten Maps in schlecht durchdachtend ausgewählten Zonen für Rush besser ist als das rechtliche Spiel.
Toxy, danke für den Sub. Huge 23 Monate. Weeb? Ernsthaft? Ach nee, Weeb, Weeble, nicht Weeb. Jetzt habe ich was verstanden.
Moment, das muss ich mir mal in Ruhe durchlesen. Ja, das frage ich mich auch. Wobei, ich finde es so geil, ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Als die Portal vorgestellt haben, haben die gesagt, Cross-Progression, das haben die immer wieder gesagt. Und das erste was ich gesagt habe ist, wie ist das mit Booster-Servern?
Dass die da nicht dran gedacht haben, wenn ein random 0815 eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung von der aktuellen Entwicklung haben der Twitch-Streamer, der noch nicht mal irgendwie Spiele-Entwickler ist, ich meine ich kenne mich zwar ein bisschen mit Programmieren aus, aber ich habe von Spiele-Entwicklung keine Ahnung.
Das erste woran ich denke ist Booster-Server und dann zum Release sind direkt Booster-Server online und ich denke mir so, warum hat da keiner dran gedacht, wenn uns das hier, mir und chat und euch halt allen klar war sofort.
Warum hat da keiner gedacht, wie kann das sein? Und ich komme immer wieder zu dem Schluss, man hat da dran gedacht, man wusste das, hat aber gesagt, nee nee, für uns fällt da gar nichts gescheites dagegen ein, naja, hau raus das Ding, hau raus das Ding.
Anderes kann ich mir nicht denken, ok, was hat er denn geschrieben? Genau, ja, wie kann das sein? Eines der Sachen diese, thanks for bringing this up, ja nein, das ist ja ganz neue Erkenntnis.
A phased approach, Leute, die Leute, die das jetzt eine Weile gespielt haben, haben eh schon alles unlocked. Und wenn nicht, spielen sie nicht mehr.
Ganz davon abgesehen, es gab zig Vorschläge auch auf Reddit und auch Dinge, die man sich ausdenken kann, die relativ einfach gewesen wären. Du könntest das festmachen, keine Ahnung, anhand der HPs der Spieler oder irgendwie limitieren Pro, da gibt's garantiert.
Also ich wette mit euch, wenn wir uns mit den Problemen von Booster-Servern hier mal eine Viertelstunde beschäftigen würden und mal ein bisschen brainstormen würden, uns würden fünf Lösungen einfallen dafür.
15 Minuten Scrum, danach Sprint, Leute.
Das sind ja Trailer, die haben die auch immer gerne in Actionfilmen und sowas, diese Szene. Und ich denke mir dann immer, wenn Boris nicht hinterher kommt, warum macht der Heli nicht einfach mal kurz ein bisschen langsamer bis Boris drinne ist?
Weil Boris hat ja den Kram in der Hand, weshalb sie gekommen sind. Warum sollte der vor Boris wegfliegen? Ich mein klar, das macht sich gut und wirkt actionreich. Aber das wirkt immer so ultragewollt, ja.
Da ist wieder das Skin, den sie letztes Jahr rausgeschmissen haben. Da ist er wieder.
Okay, ich glaube besser, besser kann man nicht beschreiben, wie abgefuckt die Benamung bei Microsoft ist. Hört euch das mal an.
Verstanden? Ja, alles klar.
Mods, waltet mal, please, eures Amtes.
Keiner da, eben war doch noch einer da. Okay, Zack. Ah, nice, Pog. Ja, Poggers hat zugeschlagen.
Also wenn das so weitergeht, ist die PS5 ordentlich lieferbar, wenn die PS6 rauskommt.
Wie? Eine weitere Möglichkeit für indische Scammers zu bezahlen wird entfernt? Was ist hier los? Gift Cards ist das beliebteste Scamming Ding. Wie können die das einfach entfernen?
Sauerei. Gut, ich meine es bleiben ja noch Android Shop Cards und alles mögliche übrig.
Ja, der Deal bei Xbox Game Pass ist ja auch ziemlich gut. Wundert mich nicht.
Ich vergesse immer, weil das das erste richtig große Hype Battle Royale war. Ich vergesse immer, dass PUBG eigentlich Pay2Play ist.
Wie kann Player Retention besser gut sein, wenn das Spiel jetzt erst rausgekommen ist? Player Retention, also wie viel da bleiben, sieht man doch erst nach zwei, drei Monaten.
Achso, hier ist es ja schon losgegangen. Ja gut, das wundert mich nicht. Das war ja noch pre-Fortnite.
Ja, das ist ja normal.
Wenn einer von euch das Spiel, meine Frage, wie sieht es denn mit Cheatern aus? Ist das Spiel Cheater verseucht oder ist das eher, man sieht ab und zu mal einen?
Was?
Und warum soll er das entfernen?
Achso, weil die es verkauft haben, aber trotzdem. Ich meine, wo ist das Problem?
Die Frage ist, ist das überhaupt verboten? Der benutzt ja kein Copyright-Material von denen. Ich meine, der patcht Sachen, die schon da sind.
Und End User Agreement ist jetzt ja nichts zwischen ihm und dem Hersteller, sondern zwischen den Usern des Spiels, oder?
Das finde ich jetzt eine interessante Frage. Bei Cheats ist es klar. Cheat-Hersteller können ja auch sagen, ja gut, die Leute sind dran schuld, aber die Hersteller werden wahrscheinlich nicht das Modding des Games in irgendeiner Art und Weise anführen, sondern den finanziellen Schaden, der dadurch entsteht.
Und dadurch entsteht ja kein finanzieller Schaden, da verkaufen im Zweifel sie eher noch mehr Geld.
Ja, das frage ich mich echt, was da rauskommt.
Ich finde das so geil, ich finde das so geil, dass sobald dann der Shitstorm kommt, dann sind sie natürlich alle wieder ganz, ganz klein laut und so nach dem Motto, nein, das war ja nie unsere Intention, hier irgendwelche Sachen zu löschen und nein, das habt ihr alles falsch verstanden. Ja, ist klar.
Was schreiben sie denn? Misunderstanding. Ach ja, bestimmt, bestimmt, komplettes Misunderstanding.
Protecting our Copyright, was ein Schwachsinn. Die haben aus irgendwelchen Gründen, was ich nicht so wirklich verstehe, aber okay, vielleicht wollten sie selbst, ich meine, es könnte ja durchaus sein, dass die selbst vielleicht einen Patch rausbringen wollten oder dass sie mit Nvidia zusammengearbeitet haben, um ein, was weiß ich, Screenshotfeature, irgendwas in der Richtung, wir wissen es ja nicht, was die da bauen.
Aber ich glaube, dass sie sich in irgendeiner Art und Weise ihre Stonks gefährdet sehen dadurch. Also Misunderstanding, ja klar. Niemand hat hier Absicht, Mods zu verbieten, genau.
Sollte das nicht, sollte das nicht Dezember schon verschickt werden?
Nachher, und was ich auch lustig finde, jeder zeigt immer nur exakt das gleiche Footage von diesem Ding, das was man damals von der Webseite gecaptured hat, bis auf welche die Glück hatten, dass sie so groß sind und mal irgendwie von Valve da was bekommen haben, aber ansonsten ist es immer das gleiche Footage.
Corona ist mittlerweile auch echt die Ausrede für alles, oder? Kannste echt für alles bringen, so nach dem Motto, wie irgendwie ich bin da und da zu schwer, Corona, wie ich habe vergessen, irgendwie meine Steuererklärung einzureichen rechtzeitig Corona, oder was auch immer.
Das kannst du mittlerweile echt für alles als Erklärung bringen, ob es stimmt oder nicht, sagst einfach Corona, was sonst? Ich habe dieses Jahr auch noch nicht so viele Videos gemacht, das liegt bestimmt auch an Corona.
Ist zu schnell gefahren, wieder geblitzt worden, muss an Corona liegen.
Jetzt auf einmal, jetzt auf einmal, die haben es draufgeschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob es auf der Maske selbst drauf steht, aber sie haben es gesagt, dass das ist und jetzt kommt raus, ist es doch nicht. Ist N95 das gleiche wie FFP2? Okay, FFP2 versus N95.
Okay, das ist im Prinzip ähnlich effektiv.
Was das Ding übrigens komplett useless macht, wenn das nicht, weil du musst ja eine FFP2 Maske haben, das macht das Ding, es ist nicht einfach nur so, dass so ein Feature wegfällt oder so, das macht das Ding von vielleicht einem sinnvollen, coolen Gadget zu absolut komplett useless, wenn es das nicht mehr ist.
Alles klar.
Die macht gute 3D-Trocker-Videos, by the way.
Jetzt ohne Scheiß, die macht wirklich gute 3D-Trocker-Videos, habe ich schon ein paar geguckt, aber das Foto ist natürlich, sage ich mal so, geeignet sich sehr gut für YouTube-Subnails.
Ja, sehr schön.
Die Sache ist halt die, hat man die sich gekauft, weil es irgendwie darauf hingewiesen wurde, die wäre quasi im Kontext von FFP2-Masken, man muss die FFP2-Masken verwenden, sonst kannst du ja auch im Prinzip gar keine aufziehen und wenn man sagt, das wäre so und man hat die sich gekauft, es ist jetzt nicht so, als ist dann einfach nur etwas kleines weg und du kannst es nicht mehr verwenden, vorher konntest du es verwenden und jetzt kannst du es nicht mehr verwenden.
Also das macht das Ding auf einen Schlag useless, das heißt natürlich sollte man da refunden, wenn sie denn, und man müsste sich das mal genau angucken, inwieweit sie das im Vorfeld gesagt haben, dass die N95 wie auch immer geeignet sind.
Wenn da einfach nur ein kleingedruckter Text drinne stand und sie haben sich da geschickt raus geredet mit, bietet ähnlichen Schutz im Vergleich zu, vergleichbar mit N95, okay, das lasse ich mir noch gefallen, dann könnte man zumindest mit Internet und Corporate Bullshit labern, draus Fluss folgern, es ist nicht N95 geschützt.
Aber haben sie das beworben und jetzt ist es das nicht mehr, musst du das Geld zurückgeben, weil die Maske von brauchbar zu useless geworden ist.
Richtig, genau, wenn die nicht FFP2 formen, kauft man die sich dann gar nicht, man würde sie sich nicht kaufen, man hat die sich nur gekauft, weil man es dachte, je nachdem wie die es beworben haben.
Und dementsprechend musst du eigentlich das Geld zurückgeben, weil du kannst es ja nicht mehr verwenden.
Bei den Amis, keine Ahnung, aber die wird ja bestimmt hier auch verkauft, oder? Wird die hier auch nicht verkauft? Weiß ich, konnte man die sich hier auch kaufen?
Oder ist das nur Kokona, Kokona Only Product?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich gucke seit ein paar Jahren schon kein Awesome Game Stunt Quick und auch kein, was war das andere, Summer Game Stunt Quick oder?
Die haben ja mal zwei Veranstaltungen. Ich gucke das nicht mehr seit der Chat Sub-Only ist.
Ich verstehe es auf der einen Seite, dass man Sub-Only-Chat macht, weil da so viel Bullshit-Grams geschrieben wurde, okay.
Aber auf der anderen Seite finde ich Sub-Only-Sachen, unterstütze ich immer aus Prinzip nicht, ich finde das kacke.
Mir ist es scheißegal, ich sage immer, natürlich entschuldigen ist billig, entschuldigen kostet kein Geld.
Mir ist es eigentlich scheißegal, ob die sich entschuldigen oder nicht.
Das hätte nur einen Sinn, wenn sie gleichermaßen auch, sagen wir mal, eine Roadmap präsentieren, unser Weg, wie wir es hier sehen, in die Welt zu gehen.
Aber, also eine nachvollziehbare Roadmap, wo man dann auch sagen kann, okay, bis da und dahin, dass man auch gleich sieht, wenn sie Mist erzählen.
Aber diese Sachen mit, so nach dem Motto, wir entschuldigen uns mal und es ist ganz schlimm und wir geloben Besserung.
Pff, who cares, wo ist denn das?
Ich glaube, es ist nicht so, wie es ist.
Wir entschuldigen uns mal und es ist ganz schlimm und wir geloben Besserung.
Pff, who cares.
Das ist heiße Luft, die es nicht wert ist, ausges froh zu werden.
Ach, haben sie entfernt, ja.
dass die Leute gar nicht mehr auf die Server gekommen sind.
Und jetzt nur der Produzenten und Direktoren Naoki Yoshida, die sich um die Spieler interessiert. Mit den limited Server-Kapazitäten am Launchen hat Yoshida erklärt, dass mehr Server überall ausgeliefert werden, was hoffentlich das Problem erhält.
Leider sind die Verlagerungen im Server-Rollout unverdächtig, da die globalen Semiconductor-Schritte...
Oh, und... Chat.
Jetzt nur der Produzenten und Direktoren Naoki Yoshida, die sich um die Spieler interessiert. Mit den limited Server-Kapazitäten am Launchen hat Yoshida erklärt, dass mehr Server überall ausgeliefert werden, was hoffentlich das Problem erhält.
Leider sind die Verlagerungen im Server-Rollout unverdächtig, da die globalen Semiconductor-Schritte...
Oh, und... Chat.
... die globalen Semiconductor-Schritte...
Wir haben noch ein Video letztens von ihm geguckt, wo er erzählt hat, er hat irgendwie
zwei Kubernetes-Clustern, einen Proxmox-Cluster, irgendwie sonst was und im Endeffekt hatte er nichts darauf laufen, außer was sich selbst verwaltet.
Die dreiste Werbung von Nutella. Das ist, ja ich wollte es auch nicht, das ist mir zu dramatisch jetzt.
Playstation-Emulator. Longest, das gucken wir jetzt, diese Videos sind immer gut.
Und gehen immer auch kurz, da lasse ich die Musik mal auch vorbei, der hat immer selbst welche, ne?
Ah, yes! Kogas! Kogas-Time! Kogas dreht sich in die falsche Richtung, guck mal!
Nee, kommt drauf an, kommt drauf an, auf welches, kommt drauf an, auf welches Zahn hat man, guck natürlich.
Chat, Chat, Moment, was, wie? Suche einen Linux-Surfer für zuhause, für kleine Projekt-Buzzlein,
kannst du Raspberry Pi... Also wenn der Raspberry Pi für dich passt, von der Leistung her und allem,
dann ist der Raspberry Pi immer noch das beste. Du kannst dir auch einen Raspberry Pi 3 holen,
die sind günstiger, wenn es dir reicht. Was Vergleichbares gibt es nicht. Ich weiß,
ich weiß, das darf ich nicht einfach so sagen, es kommt nämlich gleich wieder im Chat, doch, doch Max,
gibt jede Menge vergleichbaren Sachen zum Raspberry Pi. Ja, es gibt vergleichbare
Hardware zum Raspberry Pi, aber was Support, Tutorials und generell Hardware-Unterstützung
angeht, ist der Raspberry Pi halt einsam an der Spitze. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen
dem 3 und dem 4er? Was war der USB-C? Du hast jetzt USB-C beim 4er, du hast USB 3.1,
glaube ich, du hast ein bisschen schnellere CPU und Gigabit-Netzwerk, wobei Gigabit richtig
ordentlich angebunden ist Gigabit-Netzwerk, glaube ich mittlerweile und ordentlich RAM.
Also für die meisten Sachen, für die meisten Sachen reicht der 3er auch,
aber ich würde, also wenn ich mir einen kaufen würde, würde ich mir wahrscheinlich einen 4er
kaufen. Wo kauft man am besten einen? Naja, entweder, na gut, da guckst du einfach bei
Geizhalt, also ich habe mir bei Berry Base zuletzt eingekauft, aber da guckst du einfach
bei Geizhalt, wo es gerade billig ist, oder du kaufst dir bei Amazon irgendein Starter-Kit,
aber das ist meistens preisleistungstechnisch nicht das Beste. Ja, die Odroid-Dinger habe ich auch
drüben einlaufen, aber die sind trotzdem weit entfernt davon hardware-support-technisch wie in
Raspberry Pi. Ich habe hier bei mir im Wohnzimmer ein Odroid HC2 laufen, das ist quasi so ein
Festplatten-Rahmen mit Microcontroller drinne, also nicht Microcontroller, mit Linux, Mini-Linux-PC
drinne. Kannst eine Festplatte ranstecken, das habe ich drüben laufen bei mir im Wohnzimmer
als Server für Fernsehaufnahmen. Da hängt bei mir eine 2TB SSD dran und hier ist ein Linux mit
TV-Header drauf und am USB einen Dual-Tuner. Dafür ist es eigentlich richtig gut geeignet,
aber selbst da ist einfach Hardware-Support ein Riesenakt gewesen versus Raspberry Pi und das
Debian von denen. Haben wir nicht sogar im Stream dafür einen eigenen? Doch, doch, doch, doch,
ich erinnere mich noch. Moment, Archief-Oblords.tv, wir haben doch jetzt, nee, einfach nur Archief.
Pass mal auf. Nein, nein, ich weiß, dass ich live bin. Odroid. Geil, wenn die Suche leer ist,
krieg dich Poggers. Wer ist der Mod-Jack, der da kommt? TV-Headend? Hier. Hier haben wir das
doch sogar zusammengebaut, da ist es doch. Hier in dem Stream haben wir das zusammengebaut und wir
mussten uns einen eigenen Kernel programmieren, äh, lull. Einen eigenen Kernel kompilieren,
nein, keinen eigenen Kernel programmieren, äh, einen eigenen Kernel kompilieren, dass USB-Support
und Treiber für die TV-Karte aktuell genug war. Hier. Kann mich noch dran erinnern. Irgendwie,
ich bin es jetzt nicht mehr, aber schön war es nicht. Das ist Arch, das ist Arch-based.
Wir haben, glaube ich, wir haben, glaube ich, am Ende wirklich einen Arch-Linux draufgemacht.
Was nimmt man unter Linux am besten? ByteStrikes, du musst nicht eine Frage stellen oder einen
Comment später Ausrufezeichen Frage machen. Das ist super Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, Alter. Also,
was nimmt man unter Linux am besten für Remote-Files im Zeugs? Naja, der Klassiker ist ja NFS,
wobei ich persönlich, ehrlich gesagt, nie NFS verwende. Ich meine, wir haben NFS auf der Arbeit,
aber ich persönlich verwende einfach immer ganz normalen Samba-Server. Den kannst du von
Linux wie von Windows aus verwenden. Wenn du natürlich in Richtung reines Storage gehst,
dass du sagst, du brauchst irgendwas verteiltes unten drunter, was du ja nicht brauchst, dann
sowas wie Ceph zum Beispiel. Aber dann wird schon abgedrehter. Nimm Samba, fertig. Dann kannst du
auch unter Windows drauf zugreifen. Nicht? Warum nicht? Samba braucht mittlerweile vier
Config-Zeilen oder so, dass es funktioniert. Windows hat jetzt einen NFS-Server eingebaut.
Oh, wirklich? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das verwenden würde. Ja, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Samba-Server braucht vier Zeilen oder so, dass es funktioniert. Minimal Samba-Conf.
Der Thomas Grenn, der weiß Bescheid. Mehr brauchst du nicht. Und das da brauchst du gar nicht? Das
brauchst du nicht. Das brauchst du schon mal gar nicht. Ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher,
ob man das Global überhaupt noch braucht. Du brauchst eigentlich nur das da. Eigentlich
brauchst du nur die drei Zeilen. Guests vielleicht noch. Nee, noch nicht. Werde ich aber machen.
Das hat so gute Bewertung und ich wollte es eh schon die ganze Zeit spielen. Mal gucken,
ob ich dazu komme. Hi-IQ-Emoji. Ich erkenne nicht, was es sein soll. Ah, ein Automat,
oder? So im Casino. Zu Low-IQ heute. Ich brauche mehr Prime-Subs. Gehirn muss expanden. So,
gucken wir uns mal weiter. Was haben wir da? Wir geben mal YouTube die Chance, nochmal was
Neues vorzuhaben. Problem. Also wenn der Gamecube jetzt 20 Jahre später ein Problem hat, ich
glaube, das ist durchaus verschmerzbar. Trotz Open World. Die Sache ist, die meisten Spiele
haben Probleme wegen Open World. Nicht so nach dem Motto, du baust da Open World und
dann spielen wir es automatisch gut. Ich glaube, die meisten Spiele, die versuchen Open World
zu machen, werden eher dadurch schlechter. Ich muss mal kurz was trinken, sonst kriege
ich immer so trockenen Hals beim vielen Schwätzen. Zeitung Exposed. Oh, ein Rezo-Video. Das gucken
wir uns jetzt nicht an. YouTube möchte, nein. Alter, ruhig, zu laut. Der Trick ist, bei YouTube
ein Video starten und direkt beenden, dann fliegt es aus der Übersicht raus. Tja, nichts dabei.
Okay, was schauen wir uns jetzt an? Play GTA V remotely on original Gameboy. Das klingt gut.
Das ist zwar richtig krasse Hacker-Man-Content, aber es geht nur elf Minuten. Das heißt,
wir werden auch alle durchhalten, die es nicht so interessiert. Moinsen, this is Sebastian. Dieser
Chat ist jetzt deutsch. Ah nee, ist er ja sonst auch. And here you see me playing GTA V on my
original unmodified Gameboy. No clickbait, no video tricks. All documented and open source.
Moinsen, this is Sebastian and here you see me playing GTA V on my original unmodified Gameboy.
Warum hast du eigentlich nie was in Watch Later, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin? Moment,
was? Zack, das Ding musst du mir angucken. Ist das ein ESP32 oder ein ESP? Lass mal kurz checken, ich erkenne es nicht genau. Das ist ein ESP866, oder? Wi-Fi?
Ich mein, ich erkenne es nicht so richtig, aber es sieht so aus.
Sehr gute Controller-Wahl, kennen wir uns wenigstens mit aus. Das ist ein Espressif-Logo,
ja, aber ich erkenne nicht, was das ist. Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Naja, dass er das nicht spielt auf dem Gameboy ist uns auch klar. Er wird dadurch, ich mein,
wir wissen es ja schon, wir sind ja hier durch die ganzen Primes Up schon richtig high IQ mittlerweile.
Der Chat, der weiste schon längst vor mir, aber logisch gesehen überträgt er über diese Wi-Fi-Cardridge
Bilder von seinem PC an den Gameboy. Anders kann es ja nicht funktionieren.
Mit etwas Input-Lag, aber anders kannst du es wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Ich bin überrascht, wie flüssig das Ganze läuft. Also selbst,
also du musst ja quasi den Output vom PC an den Gameboy übertragen,
das heißt im Endeffekt, wir werden es ja wahrscheinlich auch gleich erklärt kriegen,
das Sinne mal, was weiß ich, es könnten fast 30 FPS, na nee, nicht ganz, also was weiß ich,
25 FPS oder so. Das musste er erst mal auf den Gameboy übertragen so schnell. Ich mein,
das Ding hat nichts, der Gameboy hat eine was, äh, was hat denn der Gameboy nochmal für eine CPU,
das ist nix. Irgendwie, was weiß ich, vier Megahertz oder so. Das ist richtig,
richtig nix, was da drin ist. Wir gucken mal kurz. Gameboy, Hardware, Speck, ja. Ein. Ja,
sag ich doch, vier Megahertz. Exzellent. Das ist eine richtig coole Idee, so eine Cartridge zu
bauen für ein Gameboy mit einem ESP drin, der das dann weiterleitet und übers WLAN-Dinger
empfängt. Also quasi den Gameboy zum Streaming Device machen, also quasi Stadia. Was macht
Stadia eigentlich gerade so, wo wir gerade dabei sind? Wie geht Stadia so? Googles Spieleplattform
als White Label Produkt ist schon da. Okay Leute, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich verstehe die
Überschrift nicht. Was ist ein White Label Produkt? Google Spieleplattform wird nicht
eingestellt, hat wohl eine große Zukunft vor sich. Guter, richtiger Reißer hier. Ganz sicher,
ganz sicher. Lustigerweise, dass das alles von Google Watch Block geschrieben wird.
Ich würde sagen, Stadia hatte die große Zukunft hinter sich aktuell. Was ist denn? Was ist ein
White Label Produkt? Ich verstehe die Überschrift noch nicht mal. Okay, und ansonsten interessiert
es eigentlich keinen mehr Stadia. Egal, wir gucken jetzt Gameboy-Video. Moment, Moment,
müssen wir kurz rein, kurz rein gucken. Gitterprepo, Gitterprepo, excellent. ESP32 Code, da verstehe
ich wenigstens ein bisschen was von Stream, Sketch, Secrets. Er wird nicht seine WLAN Credentials
gepusht haben oder? Ah, nee. Nee, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Er ist deutsch, garantiert.
Google ist sogar relativ übersichtlich, was er da so treibt. Also von der Länge her,
nicht, dass ich jetzt auf einen Blick das checken würde. Setup. Oh, Bit-Shift-Magic. Kein
blassen Schimmer, was hier passiert. GPIO-Pins setzen. Okay, das check ich noch. Interrupt,
okay, verstehe ich auch. Oh, big brain time hier. Aber man muss sagen, der Kram ist sogar
ordentlich kommentiert, man könnte das sogar verstehen. Aber wie wir ja alle wissen, guter
Code muss nicht kommentiert werden, weil guter Code dokumentiert sich selbst. Okay, jetzt
gucken wir uns das Video aber mal an. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich ist ein
einfaches Bild auf dem Gameboy malen, richtiger Abfuck-Assembler-Shit oder so. Ja, man darf
nicht vergessen, der Gameboy ist von 1989 oder sowas. Also einfach mal selbst Sachen
auf das Display malen ist nicht. Oh, das ist ja, warte mal. Alter, was ist denn jetzt
los? Boah, das ist ja richtig Abfuck. Wenn du auf dem Gameboy nicht einfach jetzt sagen
kannst, ich mal hier mal einen Rektangle hin, sondern du nur in deinen Teils rummalen kannst
und die dann wiederum auf dem Screen gerendert werden. Das heißt, dann kann man sich jetzt,
wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab, dann kann man sich erstmal vorstellen, wie eklig
das ist, eine Ballanimation zu machen. Um eine Ballanimation zu machen, male ich nicht
einfach oben drüber einfach hier einen Kreis oder so, sondern ich muss die Teils ändern,
immer passend dazu, wo gerade der Ball ist und dann warten bis die Teils neu gerendert
werden. Ach du Scheiße, da hätt ich ja keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Aber es gibt nichts, das auf dem Screen direkt bestimmte Teile anbricht. So in Ordnung,
um eine arbeiturale Image zu schicken, müssen wir sie in Teile schicken, die jeweils 8x8
Pixel sind. Mit einer Farbedämpfung von 2 Bits, um die 4 Schäden von Gray zu machen, die
der original Gameboy gibt, nimmt jeder Teil 16 Bits und wir müssen dann eine Teilemap
beziehen, die die Teile wieder zusammenbaut, um die originale Image zu erzeugen.
Genau, fast. Es gibt ein kleines Problem. Die Teilemap nutzt nur 1 Bits pro Teil, um die
Image zu bezeichnen, also kann es nur von 256 bestimmten Teilen auswählen. Aber der Gameboy
hat eine Resolution von 160x144 Pixel, die 20x18 Teile verwendet werden. Also brauchen wir
ein Total von 360 Teilen, das zudem ist mehr als 256. Wenn man sich die Titelscreens der
meisten Spiele anschaut, wird man bemerken, dass diese Teile jeweils mehrere Teile verwendet
werden oder dass sie nur viel freie Umgebung haben. Dies ist okay, wenn man eine Titelscreen
für den Gameboy besitzt, aber nicht, wenn man arbeiturale Images oder Videos bezeichnen will.
Glücklich gibt es ein gut erkanntes Werkaround für das. Man kann die Memorie-Range wählen.
Well known. Das bedeutet, das wissen heutzutage noch 5 Leute oder so wahrscheinlich. Obvius.
Obvius. Natürlich. Was sonst?
Okay, ich glaube, ich konnte ihm halbwegs folgen.
Exzellent. Jetzt wirst du mal Bescheid. Also falls wir jemals auf dem Gameboy ein Bild
malen wollen, dann wissen wir, wie es geht.
Ja, gut. Bei ihm ist das ja kein Problem. Er kann ja die neuen Sachen rein streamen.
Du brauchst, glaube ich, auch irgendwas Gutes, was ein normales Bild vom PC in ein schwarz-weiß
Bild umweilen, mit 4 shades of grey. Weiß ich nicht, ob da was Gutes rauszubekommen.
Da brauchst du bestimmt was gut durchdachtest. Ich glaube nicht, dass es so einfach ist mit,
so nach dem Motto, wenn Farbe überall so, dann das, wenn Farbe unterhalb so, dann das.
Denke mal, das ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Gibt eine Menge, hab ich mich doch nicht mit
beschäftigt. Hab ich überhaupt keinen Plan von. Ich hätte es mir jetzt nicht so einfach
vorgestellt. Vor allem, ach was in der heutigen Zeit, kein Problem. Wir machen einfach, warum
soll man das selbst programmieren? Wir machen einfach einen High IQ Big Brain AI-Algorithmus,
der für uns Bilder in schwarz-weiß umrechnet. Wozu selber machen? Und dann auch Blockchain
dabei und dann ist alles gut. Import Cray Scale Pile. Okay, dann hat sich die Gedanken
schon jemand gemacht. Irgendjemand musste das ja auch programmieren. Und natürlich
das dann als NFT verkaufen. Mit was trainierst du den? Na ja, ganz einfach, so wie man die
meisten AI-Geschichten trainiert. Riesen Menge an Input-Bildern und dann in irgendeiner Art
und Weise muss man sich hinsetzen und erstmal bewerten, ob das Ergebnis passt, was man haben
will oder nicht. Und dann Good Luck Have Fun. Azubis bezahlen, um es manuell zu konvertieren
als AI-Input. Ja, oder Container-Chinesen von Fiverr.
Tetris ist ja auch nicht groß. Ah, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt. Beste. Auch nicht. Könnt
ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als wir ESP32 Assembler gemacht haben hier im Stream. Das
war schon abfang-extrem. Lass mal kurz checken, lass mal kurz checken. Achieve, ich muss mal
kurz gucken, ob ich euch das noch finde. Assembler. Ah, Max, wann halt die Klappe?
Nee, das ist das auf jeden Fall kein Assembler. Wo ist Assembler-Stellz im Stream, Max? Ich
will es jetzt sehen. Wo ist es? Wo ist es? Fake News. Ich mache überhaupt kein Assembler
im Stream. Gebaited. Gebaited von meinem eigenen Stream. Ok, das hier. Oh, wir haben das, Leute,
wir haben das Aschief überlastet. Aschief ist procken. Ok, wo ist Assembler? Max, ich
will es jetzt sehen. Wo haben wir Assembler-Stellz gemacht? Hier. Hier. ADC. Move. Hier. Das
ist das richtige Wort. Hier. Oh, das ist ja eklig. Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Registrer. R1 nach R3. Sub. Was macht denn Sub R? Voreinander abziehen. Ich ziehe Regen
1 von R1 ab und schreibe es nach R0. Was mache ich da für Dinger? Ich weiß überhaupt nicht
mal, was ich da gemacht habe. Labels sind natürlich auch immer ganz toll. Braucht man
der für Loops? Ok, ich weiß nicht mal, was das Ziel war, das wir da gemacht haben. Ach,
ich weiß wieder, was wir da versucht haben zu programmieren. Wir wollten gucken. Also,
ich glaube, ich habe es gecheckt. Ich glaube, ich weiß, was ich da programmieren wollte.
Wir lesen den Wert vom Analog-Digital-Converter ein und dann gucken wir, ob der Wert größer
ist als das, was wir uns das letzte Mal gespeichert haben. Und erst, wenn die Abweichung eine
gewisse Größe hat, dann wecken wir den ESP32 auf. Das hier ist Assembler für den ultra
Low-Power-Prozessor auf dem ESP32, der übrigens mit 8 Mhz läuft, doppelt so schnell wie der
Gameboy. Guter Code dokumentiert sich selbst, da sieht man es mal wieder. Wake, Label wake
up, exit. Ok, ich habe echt keinen Plan mehr. Ach du Scheiße, es wird ja immer mehr. Es
wird ja immer mehr, was wir da gemacht haben. Was du dann machen wolltest, ich wollte gucken
Bodenfeuchtigkeit und ich wollte einen Wert über Laura zu mir schicken heim, wenn die
Bodenfeuchtigkeit unter einem gewissen Wert ist. Das ist der Friedhof ESP, genau. Unter
einem gewissen Wert ist allerdings nur die nächste Message schicken, wenn die Abweichung
groß genug ist. Weil aufwachen und Wireless Transmission machen, kostet halt sehr viel
Batterie. Das Ding soll mit Batterie laufen und wäre wahrscheinlich auch 2 Jahre auf
so einer 800mAh-Batterie gelaufen. Ok, also das sind meine super krassen Sampler-Erfahrungen.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was er hier macht. LD ist Load, oder? Ja, steht ja auch
da hinter. Load Value at Source Address into A. Aha, also hier kommt die Adresse hin und
A ist das Register in der CPU und Load A into Target. Und das hier, und das hier schiebt
dann, was? Ach nee, das ist die Target-Adress und das hier schiebt A in die Target-Adress
in RAM. Also das hier kopiert, also grob gesagt, das hier kopiert aus dem RAM in die CPU und
das hier kopiert von der CPU in den RAM. Ja, da ist er. Obvious. Oh, 43,4. Ok, ok, ok.
43 FPS, das ist ja richtig, richtig flüssig dann die Übertragung. Ah, jetzt erst mal
eine gute alte CRT-Technik, ja. Obwohl im Game Boy überhaupt kein CRT drin war, aber
das war halt damals so. Obvious. Haben wir jetzt gerade mitgerechnet im Kopf, kein Problem.
Oder, oder, oder, nachdem mir ja FPS wichtiger sind, wisst ihr was ich gemacht hätte? Ich
hätte also, ich hätte das Ganze nicht gekonnt, muss ich gleich dazu sagen, aber an der Stelle,
ich hätte wahrscheinlich das Bild einfach kleiner gemacht, dann wäre das Bild nur noch
so groß gewesen, aber dafür mit 40 FPS. Oder mit 30. Mehr FPS besser. Da könntest du bestimmt
auch einiges mit Kompression machen, ich hab da so meine Zweifel, weil der Game Boy müsste
es ja dann entkomprimieren. Ich weiß nicht ob das drinne ist. Ehrlich gesagt, beim Game
Boy.
Ich muss, ich muss da mal kurz was dazu sagen. Also es geht ja im Chat ja quasi um die, um
die so Abstraktion, in welcher Richtung da was kommt. Also, Assembler, nein, nein, ich
muss anders anfangen. Du kannst eine CPU heutzutage nicht, wie man sich das vorstellt von ganz
früher, direkt Hardware programmieren. Selbst deine CPU hat ein, quasi, wie soll man das
nennen? Ein Set an Instruktionen, die auch dort mit einer Art Firmware drin sind. Das
ist das, wenn du beispielsweise ein Microcode Update bekommst wegen Spectre und sowas. Also
sprich deine CPU kann ein spezielles Set an Instruktionen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie viele
Instruktionen so ein aktueller x86 64 CPU kann. Wahrscheinlich 580 oder sowas, weiß
ich. Keine Ahnung, hab ich mich nicht mit beschäftigt. Früher, wo du dann noch an den
Schrank gegangen bist und irgendwelche Kabels umgesteckt hast, da konntest du damals noch
wirklich ändern, wie deine CPU Dinger macht. Das kannst du heute nicht mehr. Du hast so
ein, genau, du hast, du hast ein Instruktion Set, also sprich, das unterscheidet sich dann
auch zwischen ARM und x86 und was hast du da noch? Spark und was es nicht auch alles
gibt. So. Und du kannst deiner CPU sagen, welche Instruktionen, quasi aus ihrem Pool
an möglichen Instruktionen, die der Hersteller für diese Hardware bereitstellt, du jetzt
in welcher Reihenfolge aufrufen willst oder aufrufen ist das falsche Wort, ausführen
willst. Die CPU selbst bekommt dann irgendwelches Binary Hex Zeug, aber das entspricht mehr
oder weniger eins zu eins dem, was du in Assembler auch programmierst. Assembler ist quasi so
das in Menschen lesbare Mapping des Binary geschwuppelt, was deine CPU letztendlich einliest.
Ja, da plinke ich aus dem Kopf echt nicht durch. Also, du hast dann irgendeine Instruktion,
das wäre dann, keine Ahnung, in Hex, keine Ahnung, 1e oder so. Ich weiß auch gar nicht,
wie lang so eine Instruktion ist in Bytes. Ich kenne mich da wirklich aus dem Kopf nicht
so gut mit aus. Aber du hast dann irgendeine Instruktion, du hast dann irgendeinen Binary
Wert, 1e, oder was ist denn das 1e in Hex, was auch immer, in Binary. Nachdem sich keine
Sau merken kann, dass 1e jetzt eben Zahlen voneinander abziehen ist, hast du halt Assembler,
wo dann sowas steht wie Sub oder so. Aber Sub kommt direkt dann halt diese Hex-Wert bei
raus. Deswegen kannst du ja auch Binary relativ easy disassemblern. Wie auch immer, wie nennt
man es genau? Deassemblern, weil das Binary Zeugs mehr oder weniger eins zu eins halt
mappbar ist. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass es wirklich gut lesbar ist danach. Du
weißt dann nur, welche Instruktion deine CPU nacheinander ausführt. Was es genau macht,
siehst du ja da dran nicht. Weil ganz ehrlich, wenn du ne disassemblte Hexe hast, oder irgendeinen
Binary, was du ausführst, wenn du dann irgendwie 50 Millionen Instruktionen untereinander hast,
du hast ja keine Ahnung, was das macht. Da gibt es dann wieder irgendwelche Reverse-Engineer-Dinger,
die versuchen daraus sinnvolle C-Funktionen zurückzuübersetzen, aber das funktioniert
natürlich auch nicht perfekt. Vor allem sind jegliche Funktionsnamen und sowas, die du
in C mal verwendet hast, verloren. Dafür interessiert sich ja deine CPU nicht. Ob diese Funktion
mal bei dir in C Print Hello World hieß oder nicht, weiß ja deine CPU nicht. Für deine
CPU ist in Hello World irgendein Move-Arbeitsspeicher, ein internes Register, mach das und das und
das und dann move den Kram in die RAM-Adresse, wo dein Betriebssystem deinen Konsolenprint
liegen hat. Ja, wo sind wir jetzt eigentlich her hingekommen? Ja, so und oben drüber hast
du dann sowas wie beispielsweise C, wo du im Endeffekt keinen Assembler mehr selbst
programmieren musst, sondern du hast halt bisschen höhere Sprachkonstrukte, die aber
muss man sagen in C noch ziemlich gut man im Kopf sich halbwegs überlegen kann, was
da ein Assembler rauskommen wird. Also wenn du eine Schleife in C machst, dann wirst du
dir denken können, ok, ich habe irgendwo eine Variable und ich habe irgendwo einen Jump,
wenn diese Variable größer ist als oder sowas. Also so eine Schleife, was weiß ich,
vor I gleich Null, bla bla bla, vor Schleife in C kriegst du im Kopf noch ungefähr übersetzt
in Assembler, wenn du sowas schon mal gemacht hast. Ja, das ist quasi eine Variable, wo
gezählt wird, dann gibt es einen Jump auf die Variable, entweder wieder nach oben zum
Anfang der Schleife oder eben Schleife ist vorbei und es läuft weiter. Ja, aber umso
mehr, umso höher abstrahiert das Ganze ist, umso weniger kannst du dir vorstellen, was
dann da am Ende rauskommt. Ich glaube, die wenigsten von uns könnten bei einem Konsol-Log
in JavaScript sagen, was da wirklich rauskommt. Es ist definitiv länger als irgendwie fünf
Zeit normalerweise bräuchte es dafür. Ja. Aber ihr merkt schon, es ist nicht so, als
wäre ich irgendwie wahnsinnig tief in diesem Thema drinne. So, wir gucken jetzt erstmal
das Video weiter. Das ist schon mal gut. Na gut, äh, by the way, so mal so, dass man mal
sieht, was für richtig krassen Fortschritt Hardware gemacht hat. Ich glaube, das ist
ein echt gutes Beispiel. Also der Game Boy hat ja, warum er sagt er dann immer was von
einem Megahertz, ich dachte der Game Boy Wikipedia, ich dachte der Game Boy hatte vier Megahertz,
nicht Game Boy, Game Boy, Game Pay, ich habe fast Game Pay geschrieben da oben gerade.
So, also Megahertz. 4,19. Zwei? Ja, was denn jetzt? Es ist ja auch, es ist im Prinzip
vollkommen egal. Gehen wir mal von vier Megahertz aus. Also wenn der Game, wenn der Game Boy
ein vier Megahertz CPU hat. So, das was wir hier programmiert haben in diesem Stream war
ein Ultra Low Power Prozessor mit acht Megahertz, also doppelt so schnell wie der Game Boy.
Aber die eigentliche Hardware, die wir verwendet haben, war ein ESP32 und ein ESP32 hat ein
Dual Core 240 Megahertz CPU und ein ESP32 ist quasi der Chip unter diesem Shield, also Modul
suchen. Ja, das ist so groß, also der eigentliche ESP, der ist ungefähr so groß wie der Daumen,
wie der Fingernagel von eurem kleinen Finger und das Modul, was man sich fertig kauft,
ist ungefähr so groß wie euer Daumenagel und da drauf ist, jetzt haltet euch mal fest,
da drauf ist WiFi, Bluetooth, ein Dual Core 240 Megahertz CPU und ein acht Megahertz Low
Power Prozessor. Auf einem Ding so groß wie euer Daumen, so ungefähr so dick und ungefähr
so groß wie euer Daumenagel versus den Game Boy. Also, da sieht man schon, dass ich, also
in der hier hat es extrem viel getan. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein richtig guter
Vergleich, wo man das sieht. Game Boy, das ist quasi 30 Jahre, 30 Jahre später haben
wir quasi auf einem, auf einer Fläche von einem A-Button eines Game Boys, haben wir
ein Dual Core 240 Megahertz CPU, eigentlich ein Triple Core. Ja, ne, das ist schon heftig.
So, wo sind wir jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben? Lul. So, gucken wir erstmal das Video fertig.
Nochmal eine kurze Frage zu Raspberry Pi, wäre denn ein Pi 3 ausreichend mit einem
Gigabyte RAM. Das kann ich dir nicht beantworten. Das kommt darauf an, was du machen willst.
Ich weiß nicht, was du machen willst. Was willst du denn machen? Paper, please. Das stimmt,
das ist schon echt beeindruckend. Aber ich, also das ist, das ist ja ein Vergleich, der,
wird es was weiter. Wunderbar. Das ist ein Vergleich, der immer gerne kommt, NASA PC,
der die Mondlandung ermöglicht hat. Also es geht ja im Prinzip um das, um die, um die
CPU im, in diese Mondlande, wie hieß dieses Ding, Modul, ja. Aber man muss halt mal sagen,
dass so Physikberechnungen, die die gemacht haben zur Mondlandung, und das Ding hat übrigens
auch Probleme, weil das komplett Datenoverflow hatte und nicht hinterher gekommen ist, aber
egal, dass solche Physikberechnungen tatsächlich relativ easy sind versus das, was man in Rechenleistung
braucht, um einfach nur den Safari beispielsweise zu rendern auf dem iPhone. Also es ist um
ein viel, viel, vielfaches aufwendiger, einen Browser zu rendern. Das Browser, generell
ein Browser ist ja eines der komplexesten Stück Software, die wir aktuell haben, auf
einem iPhone, als auf dem Mond zu landen. Das muss man ja auch mal sehen. Also die, die,
die puren Physikberechnungen, die die da gemacht haben, von irgendwie Anflug, Winkel, zu Schub,
zu was auch immer, ist halt einfach Mondlandung war rechenleistungstechnisch easy. Wobei man
halt sagen muss, für die damalige Technik natürlich nicht. Also du willst Website,
haust einen Fileserver, etc. Also Fileserver eignet sich Raspberry Pis prinzipiell nicht
für. Weil wenn du einen Raspberry Pi für Nas verwenden willst, ist das von der Anbindung
her doof. Also da bräuchtest du einen Vierer und selbst, selbst bei einem Vierer ist es
nicht so schön. Also für den Fileserver ist ein Raspberry Pi an sich nicht so gut. Website
hosten kannst du darauf ohne Probleme machen. Wobei ich halt, Website hosten bedeutet ja
von außen zugreifen, da wäre ich eh vorsichtig. Gut, ist das Bluetooth? Weiß ich aber nicht,
keine Ahnung. Ich würde aber nach Möglichkeit auf jeden Fall einen Vierer nehmen, wenn,
wenn es geht. Also Dreier reichen in der Regel, aber ich würde eigentlich kein Dreier mehr
kaufen. Na gut, kommen wir auf den Bereich an, aber ja prinzipiell hast du da natürlich
recht mit. Dafür schafft man heute aber auch mehr. Weil du halt nicht mal selbst Assembler
bauen müsst. Wusstet ihr, dass das erste, das erste Rollercoaster Tycoon, dass das ein
Assembler programmiert war? Das erste, das hier. Wusstet ihr, dass irgendjemand ernsthaft
dieses Spiel in Assembler programmiert hat? Ihr könnt, man kann sich glaube ich nur grob
reinversetzen, was das für ein Abfach gewesen sein muss. So was in Assembler zu programmieren.
Ich mein, einen Vorteil hat das natürlich. Ja, einen Vorteil hat das natürlich, man weiß
exakt, was ein PC macht. Wenn du irgendeine JavaScript Funktion machst, dann weißt du
nicht so wirklich, was dein PC macht. Du weißt, was am Ende rauskommt. The game was developed
in the small. 99% of the code Vorteil in x86 Assembly language. Und 1% in C. Ja, also
muss ich mal vorstellen, was das für ein Abfach gewesen sein muss. Das in Assembler
zu programmieren. Aber insgesamt schafft man heutzutage halt auch mehr. Und das ist
zumindest, sagen wir mal so, ob man mehr schafft, ist glaube ich Maßstabsfrage. Man schafft
aber auf jeden Fall mit alleine kann man krassere Dinge machen als früher. Allein schon, wenn
man sich mal, ich rede jetzt gar nicht nur von Games, aber allein schon, wenn man sich mal anguckt,
wie viel produktiver man in der aktuellen Programmiersprache ist, als beispielsweise
irgendwie Assembler oder C rumzuwurschteln, wenn es nicht sein muss. Allein schon ein popliches,
überlegt euch mal, ein popliches Kommandozellentool, was CPU Usage einliest vom System unter Linux
und irgendwie schön bunt mit irgendwelchen, also sowas hier im Endeffekt. Überlegt euch
mal, wie in Anführungsstrichen einfach man sowas mit einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache
machen kann. Überlegt euch mal, wie einfach es wäre, sowas hier zu bauen in einer ordentlichen
Programmiersprache mit der passenden Library. Nehmen wir z.B. mal Spectre Console für C
Sharp. Für Python gibt es auch alles so Libraries. Du nimmst eine ordentliche Programmiersprache,
nimmst die passende Library dazu und du machst relativ easy mit 30-40 Zeilen Code krasse
Konsolenanwendungen, die super benutzbar sind und auch optisch was hermachen. Viel Spaß,
was früher zu machen, ja. Also durch moderne Programmiersprachen, moderne Entwicklungsumgebung
und halt auch viele Open Source Libraries, die wir heute haben und GitHub und alles drum
herum ist man viel effektiver und kann auch als einzelne Person coole Sachen machen. Ja,
sehe ich auch so. Ja, das haben wir uns schon öfters angeguckt. Mein alten YouTube Channel
auf Archiv, ja. Cobol IO. Warum heißt es auch noch Cobol? Das ist ja glaube ich die
schlechteste Benahmung für eine Nass aller Zeiten. Ne, ich glaube dazu haben die nicht
die Skills. Das liegt ja auch da dran, ohne Scheiß. Finde mal, jetzt mal ernsthaft, finde
Leute, die in der Lage wären sowas wie Battlefield in Assembler zu programmieren. Wir reden nicht
mal vom aktuellen Battlefield, ja. Worst Leute, die sowas in Unity C Sharp können. Da liegen
ja mal Skill Level Welten dazwischen. Genau. Ja, sehe ich auch so. Du kannst, guck mal,
Chrome. Chrome hat mehr, wusstet ihr das, Chrome? Und nicht nur mehr, um ein vielfaches
mehr. Source Code hat als komplettes Windows. Also Chrome ist umfangreicher, um ein vielfaches
umfangreicher als Windows. Quellcode technisch. Überlegt euch mal, ich weiß nicht, wie viele
Zeilen, 12 Millionen oder wie viele Zeilen, Lines, Source Code, Chrome. Chrome hat, boah
fuck mir, 34 Millionen Zeilen Source Code. Ok, Code Lines, 25, 25 Millionen Zeilen Source
Code hat Chrome. C++. Und ich mein, wir fangen von diesem Thema ja nicht an, ihr wisst, ich
bin kein C++ Fan. Bei besten Willen nicht. Aber überlegt euch mal, jemand müsste so
ein Projekt in was anderem als in einer relativ, also, es fällt mir schwer zu C++ zu sagen,
dass es modern ist, in einer höheren Programmiersprache oder in einer niedrigeren, lowleveligeren
Programmiersprache entwickelt. Das Schöne an C++, muss man ja an der Stelle mal sagen,
ich sage selten, ich sage selten was Positives über C++. Das Schöne an C++ ist ja, dass
du den ganzen Shit nicht unbedingt verwenden musst, sondern es eigentlich zum größten
Teil als C verwenden kannst mit ein bisschen Kram dabei. Und vor den Nachteilen fangen
wir jetzt nicht an, weil C++ immer wenn ich drüber anfange, regt es mich auf. Tja, das
ist gar nicht mehr zu handeln mit, wir basteln Sachen in Assembler. Wobei ich mich nicht
wundern würde, wenn in Chrome nicht auch teilweise handoptimiert das Assembler irgendwo
drinne ist. Das könne ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen. Wir haben mit dem 18. und 19.
sehr gerne die Spiele aus den Computer-Effen abgeschrieben, wie zum Beispiel, ja du meinst
wo man irgendwelche, das war ja noch Basic, wo man irgendwelche Basic-Sachen abgetippt
hat. Da bin ich zu jung für. Ich bin 1984 geboren, dementsprechend habe ich in 80 ja
noch nicht irgendwelche Sachen abgeschrieben. Ja leider ne. So, jetzt müssen wir mal echt
mal das Video fertig gucken. Komm überhaupt nicht hinterher. Oh! Was, was manche Online-Spiele
auch so machen sollten. Vielleicht sollten wir das mal Dice schicken. Die müssten auch
mal ein bisschen synchronisieren.
Okay, der Chat hat recht, der Chat hat recht. Ihr wusstet's wieder. Crayscale.py.
Ja, wenigstens der einzig richtig gute Matrix-Film. Also der einzige. Die anderen kannst
ihr alle vergessen, die anderen sind einfach nur aus kommerziellem Interesse entstanden.
Matrix 1 ist für mich immer noch eines der besten Filme. Was heißt 1? Der einzige, ja
beste. Ich bin nicht so der krasse, wie heißt das so, Cineast oder so. Es ist nicht so,
dass ich jetzt irgendwie mir jeden Tag Trailer angucke, was Neues gibt, aber es gibt ein
paar Filme, die ich immer mal ganz gerne gucke und da gehört Matrix auf jeden Fall dabei.
Ne, der Neue ist, den hab ich mir nicht angeguckt, werd ich mir auch nicht angucken. AC 1.900,
für den Zap. Was für ein Ding. Ist das, ist das irgendein Weep? Shit. Was ist das?
Missing the music though. Remember that audio pin I dismissed as weird in the last video?
Yeah, now I wish I had hooked it up to something properly, because that would have allowed
me to also play audio. Same problem with the next request. Rick Astley, never gonna give
you up. Ja, das muss sein. Maybe I should learn to drive the Gameboy Soundtrack and blow
up on this one later. Okay, now for the big finale, the epitome of Gameboy hacking, the
apotheosis of, yeah, I spoiled it already to get you to click on the video, didn't I?
Alright, remember the one byte we are writing from the Gameboy to the ESP, the one I said
we would use for synchronization and which could be used as a backchannel? Well, let's
use it to send the state of the Gameboy controls. Eight bits, eight buttons. The ESP passes
it through to the Python script, which can now react to the Gameboy's button presses
and create any fake input on the PC. At this point, the Gameboy can be a screen for anything
and it can be an input device. Das ist ein deutscher 100 pro. Working through the remaining
requests is now as complicated as buying the Gameboy Steam. Es hat, es hat, sag mal mal
so, es hat ein bisschen Input lag. It's now as complicated as buying the Gameboy. Guck
mal, wann er da draufdrückt und wann es hier scrollt. I mean, in klein erkennt man das,
in groß erkennt man das eigentlich nicht mehr. Aber in klein erkennt man, dass es geht. Das
läuft halbwegs flüssig, muss man sagen. Ich meine, das in was hat er gesagt? 20 FPS?
Das ist, ich muss sagen, ich bin echt sehr beeindruckt davon. Du musst erst mal 20 FPS
auf den Gameboy gestreamt hinbekommen. Nicht schlecht. Ich meine, das funktioniert. Das
ist der Anfang am Strand. Okay, ich werde es tun. Natürlich funktioniert das. Das ist
ein bisschen falsch. Du siehst, Doom ist die Go-To-Demo, um auf einem Gerät zu fahren
und ich bin nicht Doom auf dem Gameboy zu fahren. Ich spiele es nur auf dem Gameboy. Ich will
nicht, dass das alles vermischt wird, okay? Wenn ein blödes Newsblock das falsch macht,
musst du es einfach sagen, okay? Schreib ihnen einen stark erwähnten Kommentar. Gut, hier
ist es dann, Doom. Was für eine Seite. Okay, das ist es. Ich glaube, ich habe es klar
gemacht, dass ich mit dem Gameboy jetzt fast alles machen kann, solange es den PC auf
der Netzung gibt. Das ist ja klar. Der streamt ja auch den Output. Das ist ja logisch. Aber
trotzdem. Also, dass das so flüssig ist, das musst du erst mal hinkriegen. Ich bin echt
beeindruckt davon. 20 FPS? Ich meine, das ist nahezu flüssig. Filme laufen heute immer
noch mit 24, weil es cineastisch. Und Konsolenspiele liefen lange Zeit auch mit 25, 30, weil
cineastische Experience. Weil man sich das schön geredet hat. Aber trotzdem, das ist
echt nice. Mehr als Battlefield 2042. Und außerdem sieht man eh nur 12 FPS pro Auge. Genau, deswegen
heißt es ja auch Battlefield 2042, weil es Battlefield 20 bis 42 FPS gemeint ist. Sehr
schönes Video. Nice. Ich wäre zwar nicht in der Lage gewesen, das selbst zu bauen
und wäre gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, aber das jetzt so mal vorgestellt, ist echt
da ist das Video gewesen. Ja, easy clap. Was haben wir als nächstes? 22 beste Dinger
bei der CES 2022. Okay, bei der CES letztes Jahr, das ist, was ist das CES? Consumer
Electronics Show. Für was steht das CES? Steht für Consumer Electronics Show. Alles klar.
Letztes Jahr gab es da sehr viel Schwachsinn zu sehen. Zum Beispiel besonders dünne LCD-Bildschirme,
wo ich mich immer frage, wer braucht noch dünnere LCD-Bildschirme? Hat jemals von
euch, hat jemand von euch jemals das Problem gehabt im Wohnzimmer, dass er gesagt hat,
ah, mein Fernseh, der ist 3 cm dick. Wäre der jetzt mal nur 1 cm dick, wäre das ganz
anders alles? Also, warum? Norders. Also, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Ich glaube,
das ist nur, weil das so ein Wettrennen ist. Das ist wie bei den Handys, wo es auch darum
geht, wer baut das dünneste und das leichteste und sowas. Und übrigens, Chet, gut, dass
es mal jemand schreibt, gut, dass es mal jemand schreibt, ich gehe wirklich davon aus und
ich bin mal gespannt, ob ich recht behalte, ich gehe wirklich davon aus, dass die nächsten
Jahre über irgendwelche Hersteller sowas versuchen werden. High-end Röhrenfernseh und
es dann wieder als das beste seit geschnitten Brot verkaufen. Mich würde es ohne Scheiß,
mich würde es nicht wundern. High-end Röhrenfernseh, allerdings nicht fürs Fernseh gucken oder
sonst was in der Richtung, weil da wissen sie, sie kriegen da auch kein 3-Meter-Röhrenfernseh
gescheit hin. Aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man versucht, ich kann es
mir noch nicht genau vorstellen, wie und für was, dass man wieder versucht, Röhrengeräte
zu verkaufen, allerdings diesmal nicht unter, so nach dem Motto, das Budget für die Oma,
sondern unter dem Gesichtspunkt, High-Performance für den Ultra-Gamer oder sowas oder High-Performance
für den Profi-Esport, irgendwie sowas. Und mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn das kommt.
Lull, warum jetzt, wo schon ein 360-Hertz-Monitor gibt, gerade deswegen. Was willst du da noch
großartig machen? Ich mein, klar, ein 420-Hertz-Monitor wär's mal irgendwann demnächst. Aber du kannst
ja eigentlich nur noch den Leuten jetzt was besseres verkaufen, wenn du ihnen sagst,
ha, du kriegst jetzt Röhre für den Profi-Gamer. Röhre für den Profi-Gamer wäre der logische
Schritt nach 360-Hertz oder 480-Hertz. Nee, 480-Hertz sind diese Fernseher mit Zwischenbildberechnung,
die gar keine 480-Hertz haben. Röhre kann jetzt 120-Hertz, das stimmt, wobei man die
Herz von einem Röhrenbildschirm nicht vergleichen kann mit dem Herz von einem LCD. Das sind
zwar komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe. Eine Röhre refresht wirklich das komplette
Bild in der Zeit. Ein LCD ruft im Endeffekt das Bild von der Grafikkarte so oft ab und
hat vielleicht schnell genug Pixel, um das auch schalten zu können. Ein LCD baut ja
nicht das Bild neu auf, im Sinne, wie das eine Röhre macht. Weil da siehst du ja allein
schon da dran, wenn man sich mal so eine Röhre wirklich in Ultra-Zeitlupe anguckt, das Bild
wird ja schwarz, wenn das nicht weiter gezeichnet wird. Bei einem LCD ist es ja nicht so, das
Bild bleibt ja so. Hast du dir eigentlich den Staubsaum mit der Sucking Station geholt?
Nein, hab ich nicht gemacht. Nein, ich hab mir den nicht bestellt. Es gibt ja keine Refresh
Rate bei LCD Bildschirmen. In dem Sinn. Der eigentliche Begriff Refresh Rate kommt ja
von Röhrenbildschirmen. Bei einem LCD ist es eine Mischung aus, wie oft ruft das Ding
von der Grafikkarte neue Bilder ab und wie schnell können die Pixel schalten auf den
Bildschirm. Eine Refresh Rate in diesem Sinne gibt es ja bei LCDs nicht. Bei einem CRT muss
ja das Bild refreshed werden, dass es überhaupt ein Bild anzeigt. Diesen Refresh gibt es ja
bei LCDs nicht. Warum das? Weil es unterschiedliche Technik ist. So, gucken wir jetzt mal, was
können wir uns als nächstes angucken? Ja, also was haben sie auf der CES vorgestellt?
Bestimmt. Ist das eine Drohne oder ist das irgendein Wi-Fi Router, der besonders futuristisch
aussehen muss? Genau, ein CRT muss sich refreshen, dass es überhaupt ein Bild anzeigt. Wenn
es das zu langsam macht, dann flimmert es. Was man bei alten CRT-Monitoren mit 60 Hz zum
Beispiel erkennt. Oder auch mit 75, wenn man so ein bisschen dran vorbeiguckt. Achso, warum
du den Roboter nicht geholt hast? Naja, ich habe es ja im letzten Stream schon so ungefähr
angerissen. Also der Grund, warum ich mir den Staubsauger-Roboter nicht geholt habe,
ist, ich hatte ja die ganze Zeit einen und bin jetzt wieder darauf umgestiegen, dass
ich einfach mal 10 Minuten lang mit dem Staubsauger dort durchflitze, wo staubig ist. Fertig.
Das geht schneller und ist simpler, als irgendwelche Staubsauger-Monitore rum... Staubsauger-Monitore?
Alter, jetzt ist vorbei. Irgendwelche Staubsauger-Roboter rumfahren zu lassen. Und ich dachte mir einfach,
ein neuer Staubsauger-Roboter macht es jetzt auch nicht anders. Staubsauger mit CRT. Staubsauger
mit CRT, das wäre sowas gewesen aus irgendeinem Science-Fiction-Film von 1990 oder so. Ja,
siehst du, wir haben ja die excellenten High-IQ-Leute im Chat. Du musst bei einem CRT, da hast du
so einen Elektronenstrahl, der fängt links oben an. Du hast vorne auf der Scheibe, so
weiß ich was, Phosphor oder sowas, irgendwas, was leuchtet, wenn es von dem Elektronenstrahl
angeschossen wird. Und der Elektronenstrahl fängt dann links oben an, Zeile für Zeile,
bis nach rechts unten, quasi diese einzelnen Pixel zum Leuchten zu bringen auf der Scheibe
vorne. So, und deswegen gibt es ja auch diese Sachen, was der eben im Gameboy-Video erzählt
hat. So H-Blank und V-Blank. Wenn nämlich der Strahl fertig ist, von links oben nach
rechts unten, dann muss der erst mal wieder von rechts unten nach links oben fahren, um
das Bild neu refreshen zu können. Und das dauert kurz. Genauso wie der Strahl für
jede Zeile von rechts nach links springen muss. Wisst ihr, was ich mich frage ist, hat
irgendjemand mal versucht, damals, also CRT baut ja das Bild so auf. Erste Zeile, nächste
Zeile, nächste Zeile, nächste Zeile, nächste Zeile, Zeile, Zeile, Zeile, Zeile, Zeile,
Zeile, Jump nach oben, Zeile, Zeile, Zeile, Zeile. So, hat mal jemand probiert, eine CRT
zu bauen, der so macht? Bestimmt, oder? Oder ist das eine dumme Idee? So, und wenn der unten
ist, wenn der unten ist, dreht er einfach um, dann baut er das Bild von unten nach oben
wieder auf. Wobei, das funktioniert nicht. Das ist dumm wegen dem Speicher und ich glaube,
das Bild würde sich dann auch irgendwie einander verschieben, oder? Ach, kein Schimmer, weg
damit. Das mir nur gerade so eingefallen. Das stimmt nicht. Das Auge sieht keine 30
FPS, das Auge sieht 12 FPS und mit zwei Augen 24. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum dieser Mythos
immer noch im Umlauf ist. Es sind nicht 30 FPS, es sind 24 FPS, was das Auge sieht. Chat,
Mensch, ich dachte, hier sind richtig high IQ Leute. Ja, mehr Augen, mehr FPS, das ist
ja klar. Das ist ja logisch. Also hätten wir drei Augen, dann würden wir dann quasi
zwölf mal zwölf mal zwölf sehen, das heißt 36 FPS. Und mit vier Augen 48 FPS. Jetzt
jetzt etwa als Dialogmaske. Deswegen, übrigens, gab es auch Probleme, wenn du was Magnetisches
neben einem CRT hattest. Vielleicht hatte mal jemand von euch einen CRT, einen Röhrenmonitor,
einen Röhrenfernseher und hatte Lautsprecher daneben stehen, zu nah dran. An den Lautsprechern
sind Magneten, dann habt ihr immer so lustige Ringe gehabt auf dem Monitor neben. Das liegt
an den Magneten vom Lautsprecher, die den Elektronenstrahl ablenken. Spinne sieht er,
ja gut, dann müsste man erst mal wissen, was die Spinne pro Auge an FPS sieht. Oh Leute,
soll ich euch mal richtig Monk W-Story erzählen? Ich bin letztens hier ins Arbeitszimmer, kann
man sagen, dass ich schon erzählt habe. Ich bin letztens hier ins Arbeitszimmer gegangen
und habe mir gedacht, so aus dem Augenwinkel, es ist ein schwarzer Fleck an der Decke. Nix
bei gedacht und da habe ich mich hingesetzt und denke mir, Max, irgendwie ist immer noch
rechts oben ein schwarzer Fleck. Guck ich nach oben an die Decke, sitzt da die ultra
fette Spinne. Naja, ultra fett. Ultra fett für uns gebreiten gerade. Spodermann, ja.
Also, die war nicht ultra fett im Vergleich zu australischen Spinnen und sowas. Ne, ne,
ne. Nein, nein, nein, nicht so was Fettes. Zumindest, ihr kennt, ich habe es nicht so
mit Spinnen, aber ihr kennt das ja, sobald man sowas sieht, man möchte das nicht aus
den Augen lassen, weil es gibt nur eine Sache, die noch schlimmer ist, als eine Spinne an
der Decke zu haben, eine große Spinne an der Decke zu haben ist, zu wissen, dass sie
da war und dass sie jetzt nicht mehr da ist. Und zu wissen, die ist noch irgendwo. Das
ist noch schlimmer. Also, was habe ich gemacht? Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt. Leute, no joke, ja. Ich
habe mein Handy angemacht und habe die Kamera eingeschaltet und habe die Kamera filmen lassen
oben in die Ecke, wo die Spinne ist und bin langsam, dass ich weiß, wo das hingeht, und
bin langsam raus, sodass sie nichts merkt und nicht der Meinung ist, da muss ich bewegen,
habe den Staubsauger geholt, habe den Staubsauger angeschlossen, habe das Ding auf volle Pulle,
2500 Watt oder was auch immer gestellt, habe ich das Ding eingesaugt und das Ding noch
3 Minuten laufen lassen.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Und nicht nur eingesaugt, ich habe danach noch ein paar Mal Unterdruck
gemacht mit der Hand am Staubsauger und danach oben extra einen großen Knäuel Klopapier
reingesteckt, dass sie nicht rauskrabbeln kann, falls sie das doch überlebt hat. Aber das
wird sie nicht überlebt haben. So, gut, dass wir das jetzt geklärt haben,
das war richtig abartig. So, jetzt gucken wir das Video.
Also, warum ich ihn immer ganz gerne gucke, ist, der zeigt meistens die sinnvolltechnischen
Sachen. Die anderen Leute, die CES-Footage zeigen, die zeigen dann irgendwelche komischen
Messergirls oder den X-LCD-Fernseher, der noch flacher ist, das interessiert mich nicht,
aber der interessiert sich meistens für ähnliche Sachen wie ich, deswegen gucke ich
ihn ganz gerne.
Sekunde, ich muss dazu mal ganz schnell das passende
Bild suchen. Natürlich ist das ein Speaker. Der Sound
beamt sich nicht zu seinen Ohren. Nein, der beamt sich nicht. Das ist ein Speaker. Natürlich
ist das ein Speaker. Was denn sonst? Das sind Schallwellen, die an seine Ohren kommen.
In irgendwelcher Art und Weise haben sie es halt geschafft, dass die nicht in alle Richtungen
gehen, sondern nur in eine Richtung. Okay, aber es ist immer noch ein Speaker.
Das geht nur, wenn du Corona geimpft bist und die Antenne am Arm hast. Dann funktioniert
das. Es ist teuer, aber das CES-Fernseher hat die Art und Weise, dass du deinen Gesicht
und Ohren bewegen kannst.
Art und Weise. Leute, wir brauchen schon Art und Weise mittlerweile, um Facetracking zu
machen. Also mittlerweile sind die Hersteller voll mit irgendeinem Bullshit. Ich glaube
nicht mal, dass er sich das ausgedacht hat. Das sagen die Hersteller. Also erstens, es
ist ein Speaker und zweitens brauchst du keine Art und Weise, um Facetracking zu machen.
Das ist totaler Blödsinn. Was kommt als nächstes? NFT-Blockchain oder was?
Übrigens, an die ganzen Leute, die schon mal in einem Shit-Repo was committet haben,
wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ihr quasi NFT-Besitzer seid? Die Comments ID von eurem Comments ist
quasi ein NFT. Also jeder comment. Ihr seid voll modern. Richtig stonks. Wirklich? Ja,
im Prinzip schon.
Oh, das ist aber teuer. Guck mal hier. 2500 Euro für eine Tür, die rein und raus fährt.
Mal ganz klar, von abgesehen, das funktioniert doch wieder nur in Ami-Häusern. Guckt euch
das mal an. Das ist eine typische Ami-Haus-Erfindung. Bei uns funktioniert das überhaupt nicht,
weil bei uns sind Steine neben der Tür. In einem normalen Haus hier hast du einen Türrahmen,
okay? Und wenn du den Türrahmen wegmachst, sind links und rechts und unten sind Steine.
Da ist überhaupt kein Platz, wo die Tür hinfahren kann. Das würde bei uns nur funktionieren,
wenn die Tür sich zusammenfalten würde. Was die ja hier bestimmt nicht macht, dann wäre
sie nämlich auch nicht stabil.
Ja, Chet, so sieht es aus. Das ist aber kein NFT. NFT ist es nur, wenn es in einer Blockchain
drin ist. Weil ich könnte ja den gleichen MD5-Summe einfach generieren bei mir mit dem
gleichen Input. NFT ist es nur, wenn es in einer Blockchain drin ist. Und die Git
History ist ja quasi eine Blockchain. Und ein NFT sagt nichts darüber aus, auch wenn
das ganz gerne verkauft wird in der Richtung. Ich habe doch extra ein Video dafür aufgemacht,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, das kann ich ja mit euch mal angucken. Ich finde, der hat
das eigentlich ganz gut erklärt. Ich habe doch extra ein Video aufgemacht. Hier, ich
finde, das habe ich gestern gesehen. Ich finde, das hat er gut erklärt. Ich hatte mich da
jetzt die letzten Wochen mal nebenbei immer schon mit beschäftigt, weil ich einfach wissen
wollte, was denn im Endeffekt hinter dieser ganzen Scheiße steckt. Und im Endeffekt ist
es zu 99% Bullshit. Die Leute haben keinen Plan, was sie da eigentlich kaufen. Und dann
bin ich auch zu dieser Analogie im Kopf gekommen, dass jeder, der schon mal einen Git-Repo-Commit
gemacht hat, eigentlich NFT-Besitzer, das heißt NFT-Besitzer ist ja das falsche Wort,
auch schon mal was mit NFTs gemacht hat. Die Git-Commit-ID ist ein NFT, also quasi
ein Token oder ein Hash-Wert, den du nicht ändern kannst. Den einzigen Weg quasi diesen
Hash-Wert zu ändern, ist es alle Hashes davor zu ändern. Dementsprechend kannst du ja quasi
sagen, die Git-History ist eine Art Blockchain. So, und das NFT weder was mit dem Besitz
von irgendwelcher Kunst zu tun hat oder irgendwelchen In-Game-Gegenständen oder sonst was, noch
dass es irgendwie dafür sorgt, dass man, was weiß ich, irgendwie da besondere Rechte
dran hätte oder so. Man kauft ja nicht die Kunst. Man kauft das Token in einer Blockchain,
was keinerlei Wert eigentlich besitzt in dem Sinn. Also ich verstehe, ganz ehrlich, was
da wieder losgetreten wurde, ich verstehe den ganzen Hype und Auflauf darum nicht. Du hast
ja noch nicht mal Rechte da dran. Also es ist ja nicht mal so, dass wenn du dir jetzt
auf irgendeiner Auktionsseite ein NFT kaufst, wo irgendwie ein Affenbild oder ein Dinosaurierbild
oder was auch immer dabei ist, dann ist es ja nicht so, als hättest du Rechte an diesem
Bild. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als dürftest du das für kommerzielle Zwecke verwenden
oder als dürftest du Leute verklagen, weil die dein Bild verwenden oder als könntest
nur du dieses Bild verwenden. Noch irgendwas, gar nichts. Du hast keine Rechte an diesem
Bild. Du hast keinen richtigen Besitz an diesem Bild. Du hast gar nichts. Du kriegst einen
richtigen Besitz an diesem Bild. Also das Bild und das NFT hat eigentlich nichts miteinander
zu tun. Das ist ein NFT. Es ist noch nicht mal ein Echtkeitszertifikat. Was bedeutet
überhaupt Echtkeitszertifikat? Also quasi das, was der Künstler ursprünglich erstellt
hat, noch nicht mal das. Du kannst ein Pixel ändern oder ist es ein anderes Bild? Es ist
ja nicht mal, dass das irgendwie geschützt wäre oder so dadurch. Es kann auch jemand
einfach dein NFT-Bild nehmen und das nochmal versteigern, quasi zu einem anderen Token.
Also die Sinnhaftigkeit der ganzen Sache habe ich noch überhaupt nicht verstanden und ich
glaube, dass das überhaupt so zurzeit trennend und ein Hype ist, liegt daran, weil die Leute
nicht verstanden haben, was es ist. Also die haben keinen Plan, was es ist. Ich will nicht
sagen, dass ich es hundertprozentig jetzt überschauen könnte, dass es da nicht noch
andere Gründe gibt, warum man das macht, außer man möchte halt so diese typischen, außer
man würde auch bei irgendwelchen Pyramiden-Dingern mitmachen. Pyramiden, wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Pyramiden-System, mitmachen. So nach dem Motto, man möchte den Kram weiter verkaufen
an Leute, die eigentlich auch keine Ahnung haben, was sie da eigentlich haben. Also kein
Schimmer. Ich verstehe es nicht. Es ist die Frage, was echt bedeutet. Nein, kannst du
nicht. Ich kann das Bild. Also mal angenommen, du ersteigerst dir so ein Bild, was du ja
nicht machst. Was du ja nicht machst. Mal angenommen, du ersteigerst dir das. Machst
das zu deinem Twitter-Avatar. Ich sage, rechtsklick, speichern unter von deinem Twitter-Avatar
und versteige das neu. Kann ich machen, überhaupt kein Problem. Überhaupt kein Ding. Es ist
ja nicht so, als hättest du da irgendwelche, wäre das irgendwie geschützt oder so. Du
kannst es auch screenshotten. Und NFT ist doch nicht mal das Zertifikat. Der NFT hat
mit diesem Bild gar nichts zu tun. Vielleicht gibt es da in Zukunft noch irgendwelche Sachen,
aber der NFT ist eigentlich nur ein Hash-Wert in einer Blockchain, das nichts mit dem Bild
zu tun hat. Also entweder, es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten, entweder ich habe das grundsätzlich
falsch verstanden, was ich mir aber nicht vorstellen kann, weil das an sich eigentlich
alles recht logisch klingt, oder die Leute haben keine Ahnung, was sie da eigentlich
machen. Nein, man kann keine, wie willst du da Rechte dran aushandeln? Es ist ja nicht
so, als wäre dieses Bild in der Blockchain gespeichert. Ist es nicht? Die Bilder liegen
auf Dropbox oder so. Und wenn du es ersteigern hast, kriegst du einen Download-Link auf Dropbox.
Du kaufst genau, du kaufst eine Zahl im Endeffekt. Du kaufst einen Hash-Wert aus einer Blockchain,
die mit diesem Bild nichts zu tun hat. Und auch diese Geschichte, was Ubisoft da erzählt
hat, in-Game-Items auf NFT-Basis oder so. Hat jemand im Kopf, wie dieses komische Ding
von Ubisoft noch mal hieß, was die Quarz oder so, oder? Quarz? Ubisoft? War das? Nee,
Quarz. Wie hieß das denn? Quarz? Quarz? So, also, diese Items haben nichts mit dem eigentlichen
Token zu tun. Ist ja auch ganz klar, wenn man sich das anguckt, wir müssten uns das
mal anschauen, wenn es da wirklich so weit ist. Also wenn ich irgendwas von irgendwelchen
In-Game-Items faseln, das sind digital erstellte Models dann quasi. Also sprich, irgendeiner
ist in Blender gegangen oder in irgendeinem 3D-Model-Programm, hat dieses Item erstellt.
Das ist ja nicht so, als wäre dieses Item jetzt irgendwie gespeichert in irgendeiner
Blockchain oder so. Das Item ist, keine Ahnung, in einem Blender-Format oder so. Guck dir mal
das YouTube-Videos an, digitaler Echtheitsnachweis, so funktionieren NFTs. Könnte man wirklich
danach machen? So, gucken wir uns aber erstmal das an.
Ja, genau, genau, ByteStrike, so ist es. Aber was, der das ganze Ding in Frage stellt?
Nicht, dass Asset in die Blockchain, sondern die Berechtigung, dass man das Item benutzen
kann, kommt in die Blockchain. Ja, schön und gut. Es ergibt aber aus technischer Sicht
absolut keinen Sinn, warum man das in die Blockchain schreiben sollte. Wenn ich mir
dafür in den Spiel einen Account anlegen will und dann ein Item drinne freischalte,
dann steht in irgendeiner Datenbank ein Flag, hat Zugriff auf dieses Item. Das Item muss
immer noch in das jeweilige Spiel eingefügt werden und muss immer noch die Funktionsweise
programmiert werden in dem Spiel, dass ich das Item was auch immer aufsetzen kann oder
was weiß ich. Wenn ich in Game irgendwie einen Pad freischalte oder so, dann muss immer
eine Animation für das Pad designen, einer muss das Pad machen, einer muss in Game irgendwie
programmieren, ein Item, mit dem ich es beschwören kann, es muss irgendwie die, in welchem Random-Modus
sich das rum bewegt, das Pad muss einer programmieren. Und ja, natürlich, man kann sicherlich irgendwelche
Sachen in irgendeiner Blockchain, was auch immer, aber warum, wozu? Das ergibt überhaupt
keinen Sinn. So, wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video fertig an.
Ach komm. Guck mal, ist das der Sensor? Das heißt, wenn
eine Katze da unten durchläuft, wird ihr der Schwanz abgehackt oder was? Schonmal keine
so gute Idee. Nein, nein, nein, nein, sorry, aber, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Automated Doors
sind garantiert nicht die Future. Schon wieder! Ein weiterer flacher Bildschirm, ganz wichtig,
der alte war 1,5 Zentimeter, der ist 1,3 Zentimeter, alter Poggers.
Tja.
version govi showed up at CES for the first time with some new lights a computer immersion kit
that's gonna come out sometime this year with new light strips and light bars they're also showing
off their rope light that came out a few months ago it's a brand new 3d glide hexa wall panels
it's similar to normal wall panels you might have seen also ja ich verstehe was du meinst
ich verstehe was du meinst aber der hersteller will natürlich wenn du also erstens die frage
hat der hersteller überhaupt interesse daran dass diese items getraded werden können wenn
ja möchte der hersteller selbstverständlich gebühren von den transaktionen dieser items haben
was ja bei einer externen plattform schwierig wird und die wollen nicht nur die wollen nicht
nur gebühren von den transaktionen haben bei irgendwelchen nft in game items oder so die
wollen im zweifelsfall auch komplette kontrolle über die plattform haben wo die drauf getauscht
werden weil die hersteller wollen immer macht auf ihre sachen auf auf ihre produkte und dinge
ausüben das wäre glaube ich ziemlich bescheuert von einem hersteller auf einem externen platt
marktplatz ihre items handeln zu lassen kein wunder dass die hersteller kein hersteller mag
dass in game items auf ebay gehandelt werden zum beispiel also die wollen ja gerade einfluss
darauf haben so und mal ganz davon abgesehen nur weil ich dieses item dann ja was auch immer
besitz bedeutet besitze heißt es auch lange nicht dass das item dann auch in jedem spiel
funktioniert oder so also wissen wir ich meine das ist das ist ein stinknormales in game item wie
jedes microtransaction item auch das muss irgendjemand modeln irgendjemand programmiert
irgendjemand in das spiel einbauen so und wenn ich mir jetzt das item irgendwo kaufe
dann ist das auch nur verfügbar in spielen wo das jemand für dieses spiel gemodelt und
einprogrammiert hat also also vielleicht bin ich dazu boomer für aber ich verstehe den sinn
absolut nicht dahinter ja und markt für marktplatz brauchst du auch keine blockchain wozu ja und hier
gehört danach auch nichts an diesem twitter twitter post ja super das kannst du machen ja
aber dann haben die hersteller trotzdem keinen einfluss auf den marketplace und das wollen
sie haben ach ja übrigens wenn das server vom spiel abgeschaltet wird ist auch dein nft item
weg also ich so ganz verstehe ich nicht und ich vermute der hype und die begeisterung kommt daher
dass es sonst auch keiner versteht also ich also ich bilde mir ein ich habe zum größten teil die
technik drumherum verstanden und ich verstehe nicht warum man darauf so abgeht und ich kann
es nur daraus schluss folgern dass den meist nicht klar ist was da eigentlich abgeht
richtig bei strikes genau wenn die server abgeschaltet werden dann hast du da nft noch
aber das was in irgendeiner art und weise dann bei dem jeweiligen spiel dran gebunden ist
nicht wobei da war man ja schon sieht du hast da keine kein besitz dran die gehört davon nichts
das hat nichts damit zu das einzige was du hast ist eine hasch ein haschwert in der blockchain ja
geil nichts wofür man irgendwie blockchain bräuchte an dieser stelle
dass die leuchtswerte hat nicht ein
ok wo sind verstehen ich habe jetzt gar nicht aufgepasst hier voll auf voller blockchain also
led stels das würde mich ultra irritieren so was auf dem schreibtisch zu haben weil also
mir geht es zumindest so wenn ich irgendwas an der seite habe was licht reflektiert oder
irgendwas was blinkt so aus dem augenwinkel ins augen rein irritiert mich das immer extrem
ok ist wahrscheinlich teuer das ganz wichtig muss muss sein 350 euren ich sage euch mal was ist
war ganz im ernst diese ganze ubisoft nft geschichte wenn das launch wisst ihr was das im back end
sein wird das wird eine stink normale postkreis datenbank sein ohne blockchain ohne ai ohne nft
ohne irgendwas das wird ein shop mit einer datenbank im hintergrund und man labeled als nft weil nft
hype so wird es laufen im endeffekt so water by sucking it back up and using it again it's
pretty cool and remind me of the suits on dune recycling sweat there are three stages of filtering
and it does need to be cleaned every few weeks if you're one who pees in the shower don't tell me
down in the comments but you can change modes to not recycle temporarily so they got you covered
you can pre-order it now for 3500 dollars and it ships at the end americas first wifi enabled moment
was was das habe ich nicht gecheckt sorry wir müssen jetzt auch noch mal den dead joke anhören
mit ins klo pink in die dusche pink ich hab sie nicht verstanden was soll das sein rainstick
and they made a shower that recycles water it's a shower recycles normalerweise passiert das schon
automatisch wenn man eine ordentliche kanalisation hat oder ist das ist das irgendwas für in der
wüste percent water by sucking it back up and using it again warum ach so zum ach so meint er
was wasser wasser sparen was ist nicht der sinn von dem wasser aus der dusche dass man den dreck
damit runter wäscht und wenn man das wasser einfach wieder hoch pumpt dann kriegt man dreckiges wasser
ab oder so oder wird es dann durch irgendwie den filter gepresst oder so
weiß nicht wasser in der kanalisation wird nie wieder verwendet wofür sind denn kläranlagen
und sowas dann da dachte es ist gerade der sinn davon oder nicht wie ist das chat erklärt es mir
wieder in die flüsse aber du wirst es nicht benutzen und wo kommt das wasser dann her wenn
ich aus dem fluss ich habe keine ahnung was keine gute frage wie funktioniert das eigentlich ich
dachte das kommt letztendlich aus dem fluss wo kommt es denn sonst her
wo kommt das wasser her wo kommt das wasser her was bei mir aus dem aus dem wasserhahn kommt
und unterirdischen wasseranlagen
ok ich sehe dass keiner so genau weiß im chat ich auch nicht deswegen machen wir einfach weiter
also jetzt ich wollte mir diese dusche angucken jetzt chat jetzt hier konzentraten nicht die
summa aufmerksamkeit spanne hier wieder antraglich also wifi enabled dusche aber wenn es aus dem
grund wasser kommt dann versickert es doch danach wieder oder wie egal egal dusche dusche
ok jetzt haben wir den witz noch mal alles klar
was warum sollte ich dir den puls von meinem hund überprüfen müssen
ok chat weiß bescheid also kläranlage reinigt das wasser soweit das muss
im fluss gar das trinkwasser dass du aus dem wasser kommt sich aufbereitet das wasser woher
das kommt hängt von wohl ab grundwasser quellwasser regenwasser zistern wasser flüssen sehen sind
möglich ok aber was ich in der grundschule gelernt habe ist folgendes unabhängig von
von unserem wasser wasser usage also das wasser fließt quasi von den bergen runter so durch flüsse
ins tal irgendwann ins meer so im mehr verdunstet das dann und dann regnet es wieder und das ganze
geht von vorne los oder das habe ich in der grundschule mal gelernt so was in der richtung
und was wir dazwischen machen ist doch eigentlich vollkommen egal solange wir es wieder in fluss
pumpen danach ok weiß ich muss jetzt wissen warum ich überprüfen muss was mein hund für
eine herzfrequenz hat
4G LTE gut funktioniert in deutsch hat schon mal richtig weil man LTE geschützt abgeschaltet
hat
wieviel wollen die? 1.400? sind die noch bei sinnen oder was? 1.400 Dollar das kannst
du in euro übersetzen die preise sind ja meistens dollar euro wahrscheinlich sind euro sogar
noch 1.500 aber was kann das ding hat es eine eingebaute drohne die morgens dann irgendwie
mir das klopapier aufs klo bringt oder was oder was rechtfertigt diesen preis das ist
bestimmt AI blockchain nft staubsauger
3k
Okay, Reactive AI Obstacle Recognition, die Sache ist die, die mittlere Generation von
Staubsauger-Robotern. Also nicht die erste, die einfach nur dumm gegen die Wand gefahren ist und
random rum, so die mittlere Generation, die oben schon dieses Radar-Ding. Da gab's ja glaube ich
zwei verschiedene Technologien. Das eine war irgendwie so ein Laserstrahl, der rumfährt und
das andere war irgendwie Radar-Stellz. Zumindest damit konntest du eine komplette Map des Raums
erstellen lassen, schon. Ohne Kamera und ohne AI. Das hat dann einfach radartechnisch deinen
Raum abgetastet und dementsprechend hat das eigentlich ziemlich gut funktioniert. Das war
leider genau. Das hat relativ gut funktioniert. Was nicht funktioniert hat zum Beispiel war, wenn
auf dem Boden irgendwie Kinderspielzeug kleines gelegen hat oder sowas. Das hat das nicht erkannt.
Aber sage mal 99% haben ziemlich gut funktioniert ohne Reactive AI und ohne Kamera vorne dran. Ich
kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das mit Kamera und Bilderkennung nochmal eine ganze Ecke besser
funktioniert. Das will ich jetzt gar nicht bestreiten, dass das besser funktioniert. Die
Sache ist nur die, ich hab keinen Bock auf den Staubsauger-Roboter mit Kamera. Und für mich
funktioniert das hier gut genug, dass ich auch keinen mit Kamera brauche. Dass die Chinesen
endlich mal Live-Bild haben, genau. Die Kokomods brauchen das. Wobei die Kokomods sind ja nicht
die Chinesen. Hat jemand eine gute Idee? Ich mein wir haben Kokomods für die Russen. Wir haben
Kokona für die Amis. Wo habe ich denn meinen Kokona überhaupt? Wir haben Kokona für die Amis.
Was? Was? Wir brauchen was für Chinesen. Nam. Ja, nee. Irgendwas, nein, irgendwas mit dem Kokona-Typ.
Kokona, genau. Irgendwie, die Ideen überzeugen mich alle nicht richtig.
Ja, Franzosen haben wir schon ein paar Sachen. Bayern haben wir auch schon. Wir brauchen noch
irgendwas für die China-Chinesen. Haben wir hier gar nicht. Wir haben Bayern, wir haben Franzosen,
wir haben Russen, wir haben Amis. Aber wir haben nichts für die Chinesen.
Ich habe da letztens ein Video geguckt und das war ernüchternd, um es mal nett auszudrücken.
Da hast du dann irgendeinen Typ, der mit 20 kmh dich durch den Tunnel fährt.
Na ja, zip. Die fahren nicht da mit 20 kmh durch. Das ist jetzt ja vorgespult. Die fahren nicht
da mit 20 kmh durch, wo man halt sich echt fragt, okay, warum muss das unterirdisch sein und was ist
die Existenzberechtigung des Ganzen? Moment, Moment, Moment. Die Autos fahren nicht autonom.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das letzte Video, was ich davon gesehen habe, da saß ein Fahrer vorne.
Da saß ein Fahrer vorne, der nicht mit 20 kmh durchgefahren hat. Leute, danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit. Okay, das ist cool. Das ist cool. Die Frage ist halt nur, ob das lange
Zeit Outdoor Usage aushält. Das ist cool. Nicht, dass man es in irgendeiner Art und Weise brauchen
wird, aber das ist cool. Ich glaube nicht, dass das nennenswerten Einfluss auf Stromverbrauch hat
oder ist das überhaupt eh? Wahrscheinlich. Wie sie jetzt alle Autos machen. Also wenn ich mir,
wenn ich das mal mit der Playstation vergleiche, dann will ich kein Auto von Sony haben. Also
entsprechend zur Playstation wäre das in der Regel so, als wenn man das mal so analogie zum
Auto zieht. Ich spiele jetzt nicht auf Verfügbarkeit oder sowas an, sondern technisch ziemlich gut,
Software technisch absolute Katastrophe. Ich glaube, dass so ein Auto will ich nicht haben.
Das Ding sieht mega beschissen aus. Ich meine, es ist ein Posttruck. Das muss nicht gut aussehen,
aber es sieht schon hardcore scheiße aus, oder? Übrigens, wusste du, dass die Post in Deutschland
auch mal Elektroautos ausprobiert hat und dass die jetzt wieder eingestellt wurden,
weiß ich nicht, gelohnt hat. Das waren so kleine gelbe Autos. Weiß ich, wie ich die Dinge anders
beschreiben soll. Kleine gelbe Autos. Doch, doch, die fahren noch, aber es gibt keine neuen mehr.
Also man hat das, man hat das, man möchte das nicht, die war die letzte News dazu, wer weiß,
ob sich das schon wieder anders überlegt haben. Dies wollen sie nicht weiter verfolgen. Ja,
ja, die fahren bei uns auch noch, aber die wollen nichts neues mal machen. Hab ich gelesen.
Okay, weiter. Was ist denn eine EV-Option? Heißt das Electric Vehicle oder sowas? Also Elektroauto?
EV? Yep. Also, Zenglet, das kommt ja bestimmt aus Shenzhen oder so. Das ist bestimmt China-Chinesen
Kram. Aber eins haben die, eins haben die für den nordamerikanischen Markt schon mal genailt,
wie man so schön sagt. Die haben eine Gruppe, eine möglichst diverse Gruppe aus jungen Leuten,
die sich freuen, Zenglet verwenden zu können. Kennst du gratis Webhousing, was keine Datenklaue ist?
Gratis Webhousing, also du kriegst bei Strato für ein Euro im Monat einen Server. Das war jetzt
nicht der Wahnsinn, aber für kleine Sachen reicht das aus. Oder du gehst in die Oracle Cloud,
da gibt es doch sogar eine halbwegs gute Kiste kostenlos, hat letztens jemand geschrieben. Wie,
Moment, Moment, was? Eine Gesundheitsglühbirne, habe ich das jetzt richtig gehört?
Was? Was zum Teufel? Was, was, was? Hä? Moment, Moment, ich blicke nicht durch.
Health Bulb? Ja, eine Gesundheitsglühbirne. Bluetooth-Mesh-Health-Monitoring. Alter,
jetzt wollen, denen fällt sonst nichts. Sinnvolles fällt denen nicht immer ein, oder? Auf der anderen
Seite, okay, vielleicht, vielleicht soll ich das jetzt mal nicht so sehr flamen. Wenn das gut
funktioniert und man damit wirklich zuverlässig erkennen könnte, ob der Opa beispielsweise
umgekippt ist, also hingefallen ist oder so und jetzt in der Küche liegt, okay, dann ist das
wahrscheinlich gar nicht schlecht. Ja, warum nicht? Dafür gibt es Apple Watch. Die Apple Watch ist
ja dafür da, dass es dir sagt, wenn du schwanger bist, dass du ins Krankenhaus musst. Haben wir
doch letztens bei Apple gelernt. Measure Selected Functions. Okay, da habe ich meine Zweifel,
ob das ordentlich funktioniert. Mein Puls messen mit einer Lampe. Also, also das andere zu
erkennen, wenn einer umfällt, das hätte ich mir in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch erklären
können, wenn man da so was einbaut, wie beispielsweise beim Staubsaugeroboter, wo das
Ding auch den Raum mapen kann. Irgend so ein Radar-Sensor. Wenn man so was einbaut und erkennt,
hey, jetzt steht einer im Raum und jetzt liegt er im Raum in irgendeiner Art und Weise, das
kenne ich mir noch, das hätte ich mir immer noch gefallen, aber dass das Ding erkennen kann,
was ich für einen Puls habe. Ich bin skeptisch, ob das funktioniert.
Sie sagten, dass es zu schlafen kann oder vielleicht sogar zu entdecken, wenn eine ältere Person
herunterfallen. Cool, oder? Ich meine, wer möchte extra-karikuläre Aktivitäten in
deinem Zimmer, die mit einem Smart-Light-Bolbe verpasst werden? Natürlich würden CES nicht CES sein,
ohne viele Roboter überall zu haben. Sie haben uns geschlagen, die Wegwege aufgenommen und
versucht, uns reinzulegen. Einer der Roboter, der eigentlich ziemlich nützlich ist, ist von
Labrador. Sie können einen Schaum fangen und ihn umdrehen. Perfekt für Trinken oder Medizin,
mit denen mit Liminen. Das ist genau das Richtige für mich. Dann sitze ich noch mehr am Computer
und kriege auch noch was zu trinken gebracht und muss nicht mehr die Treppe runterlaufen.
So lustig man sich jetzt darüber machen kann. Ich gehe tatsächlich davon aus, dass in Zukunft
sowas immer mehr Abnehmer findet und auch immer besser wird. Weil wenn man sich anguckt,
dass die Leute immer älter werden und jetzt schon viele Leute Probleme haben, auch geldtechnisch
im Alter zurechtzukommen, die sich da vielleicht gar kein Pfleger oder irgendwie Heim oder sowas
leisten könnten, ist das durchaus was, was ich mir vorstellen kann, was das Leben in den eigenen
Verwenden weiter ermöglichen könnte. Also gerade im medizinischen Bereich, die Japaner haben es uns
gezeigt schon vor 20 Jahren. Jeder kennt wahrscheinlich noch diese komische Robbe,
die im Alte... Ihr kennt die bestimmt auch noch, oder? Diese weiße Robbe, die sie da in japanischen
Altersheimen verwendet haben damals. Das wird bei uns wahrscheinlich auch immer mehr zunehmen. Wir
sind bei sowas ja immer 20, 30 Jahre hinten dran. Sobald es Wall-E gibt, kaufe ich mir Wall-E. Wall-E
war top. Wall-E ist für mich der beste Animationsfilm von allen bisher. Wall-E ist
einer meiner absolut Lieblingsfilme. Vor allem, weil die Menschen da auch alle so pepo-fett sind.
Habt ihr Wall-E geguckt? Die Menschen sind alle richtig... Die Menschen sind so wie wir quasi,
die sitzen den ganzen Tag rum und sind fett. Sanji, 1reiter7, Dankeschön für den Sub. Wall-E ist top, ja.
Und die haben dann auch so einen Stuhl, der sie überall rumfährt und sowas.
Funktioniert der Hetzer-Link noch? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe es dieses Jahr noch nicht
ausprobiert. Offiziell funktioniert der Hetzer-Link nur bis 31.12.2021. Leute,
ich habe gar nicht in meine Mails geguckt. Zack, das muss ich jetzt mal schnell machen. Nicht,
dass ich irgendwelche highly zeitkritischen Business Activities hier verpasst habe oder so.
Das geht ja gar nicht. So, erstmal in die Business-E-Mail gucken. Was ist hier los?
Ah ja, ich habe schon ganz viel verpasst. So, jede Menge VPN-Anfragen.
Was ist das denn?
Okay, keine Ahnung, das muss ich jetzt mal in Ruhe angucken. NordVPN ist auch wieder am Start.
Leute, soll ich NordVPN bewerben? Wie sieht es aus, NordVPN? Auf geht's. Wollen wir NordVPN
zu laut machen? Ich habe zwar mal ein Video gemacht, VPNs sind doof oder sowas, aber warum
nicht? Warum nicht? Ich schicke das mal meinem Manager weiter. Wie ihr wisst, ich habe jetzt
einen Manager. Ich hätte selbst nie gedacht, dass ich mal sowas habe, aber forward. Forward.
So. Okay, weiter geht's. Also, schauen wir uns mal an, was passiert hier. Der Manager
ist auch agil, er ist richtig krass. Angel. Netzwerk, der hat mit dem Netzwerk nichts zu tun.
Smart Slider. Irgendwie, vielleicht interpretiere ich da zu viel rein, aber der Name hört sich
sehr gut an. Man hat davon abgesehen, sowas gibt es auch schon eine ganze Weile. Ja, Moment,
das funktioniert bei beispielsweise Terrassentüren oder sowas mit Slidern und Dingen, wo Platz
ist. Bei einem normalen Fenster funktioniert das nicht. Was? Was zum Geier soll das gewesen
sein hier? Man wiegt sich, indem man da dran zieht oder was? Das kann doch überhaupt nicht
funktionieren. Ach, Körperfettmessung. Nicht, nicht wie viel man wiegt. Ach, Körperfettmessung.
Okay, okay, vielleicht. Das Körperfettmessung kann ich mir... Aber Gewicht kann so nicht
funktionieren. Ja, okay, wenn du dich draufstellst, ist Gewicht okay. Ach, denn die steht unten
irgendwo noch drauf oder so. Ja, dann ist es was anderes. Okay, das ist was, wenn man
sich noch unten drauf stellen muss und gleichzeitig daran ziehen, dann lasse ich mir das irgendwie
gefallen. Aber einfach nur dran ziehen? Nee, vor allem nicht für Gewicht. Wie soll das
funktionieren?
Warum, jetzt mal ernsthaft, warum muss dieses Ding Spotify unterstützen? Also, was ich damit
sagen will, ist nicht, dass es schlecht ist, dass es Spotify unterstützt. Was ich damit
sagen will, ist, warum nimmt das nicht einfach random Musik, warum lässt sich das nicht
einfach wie jeder x-blibische Kopfhörer per Bluetooth pairn und du spielst das auf deinem
Handy ab und die Musik kommt da drauf an? Warum sollte ich denn meine Headphones mit
Spotify verbinden wollen? Pairn als Bluetooth ungut ist? Das sieht unbequem aus beim Schlafen.
Ich frage mich gerade, wie man das ins Ohr macht. Also, ich meine, das da kommt ins Ohr.
Das bedeutet, das da kommt hinten an den Kopf, oder? Das da ins Ohr, das da hinten
an den Kopf. Also, um ehrlich zu sein, ich brauche keinen White Noise, wenn ich ehrlich
bin. Ich möchte eigentlich einfach Ruhe haben, wenn ich schlafen will. Einfach nichts. Einfach
Ruhe finde ich eigentlich am besten zum Schlafen. Ja, wie, ich dachte, wir kriegen das jetzt
mal gezeigt, wie man das verwendet. Wobei, das durften die da bestimmt nicht zeigen,
weil die nicht wollten, dass sich das jeder in seine Ohren klatscht. Dann spiele doch
auf YouTube ein Video ohne Sound-Loud ab. Five Head Comment. Ich verliere mein Wallet
nicht. Wallet auf Brieftasche. Brieftasche. Ich verliere meine Brieftasche nicht. Und
die Leute, die mich hier schon länger verfolgen, die wissen auch, warum ich meine Brieftasche
nicht verliere. Wisst ihr, warum ich meine Brieftasche nicht verliere? Mal gucken, wer
das weiß. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Du hast keine, richtig. Richtig, ich habe keine.
Kann ich auch nicht verlieren. Und weil ich nicht rausgehe, das stimmt. Weil ich fett
bin und nicht rausgehe, korrekt. Aber ich habe keine Brieftasche. Was hast du dann?
Eine Hosentasche. Und in diese Hosentasche kommt genau die einzigen Sachen rein, die
wichtig sind. Perso nehme ich nicht mit. Hörerschein brauche ich nicht. In die Hose
kommt mein Smartphone und je nachdem, was ich vorhabe, 10 bis 20 Euro in die andere
Seite. Fertig. Das hättest du besser für dich behalten sollen. Warum? Man ist nicht
verpflichtet, seinen Personalausweis mitzunehmen. Du musst einen haben. Du musst sie nicht mitnehmen.
Weiß gar nicht, woher dieses Gerücht kommt. Du bist nicht verpflichtet, dazu deinen Personalausweis
mitzunehmen. Du musst dich ausweisen können. Du musst den Ausweis aber nicht mitführen.
Du musst einen haben. Du musst ihn nicht mitnehmen. Du kannst dich doch ausweisen. Du kannst dich
doch ausweisen. Du sagst, ich habe den Ausweis dabei. Ausweisen kann ich mich. Du musst ihn
nicht dabei haben. Und ich nehme ihn auch nicht mit. Wisst ihr warum ich ihn nicht mitnehme?
Weil dann die Gefahr besteht, dass ich ihn verliere. Wie ich mich ausweisen will, wenn
ich ihn nicht dabei habe. Ja nicht vor Ort. Das muss ich aber auch nicht. Musst du nicht.
Du musst einen haben. Du musst einen gültigen Ausweis haben. Gültig kann man sich noch streiten,
aber im Zweifel musst du Bußgeld bezahlen, weil er nicht gültig ist. Aber du musst ihn
nicht mitnehmen. Was ist mit in den Laden gehen? Ja wenn die einen Ausweis haben wollen,
mich sonst nicht rein lassen, dann kann ich da nicht rein. Aber in der Regel, also zumindest
das letzte Mal wo ich essen gegangen bin, die wollten meine Corona Impfzertifikate sehen
auf dem Handy und sonst nichts. Doch Zugticket wird kontrolliert. Achja, das habe ich ganz
vergessen. Das nehme ich auch noch mit. Zugticket und Zugangskarte für die Arbeit, das habe
ich, das habe ich alles in einem. Das habe ich einmal an so einem Clip dran. So ein Clip,
was man, kennst du das mit so einem Gummiband? Mit so einem Ausziehband? Das clips du dir
nebenan die Hose und das ist so eine durchsichtliche Karte. In dieser durchsichtlichen Karte ist
mein Zugangskarte für die Arbeit drin und auf der Rückseite meine Fahrkarte. Ne, Zugticket
nicht in der App. Zugticket ist noch oldschool. Ich habe Zugticket oldschool, weil wir haben
ein Jobticket und das Jobticket kriege ich einmal im Jahr per Zettel zugeschickt. Ist
halt so, kann ich nichts machen. Muss jetzt mal gucken, wo das überhaupt ist. Ich glaube,
ich habe für dieses Jahr noch gar keins. Müsste ich mal schauen. Ich würde gerade
mal aufschreiben. Jobticket. War gespannt. Okay, schauen wir mal weiter. Also für alle
Leute, die öfters mal ihre Brieftasche verlieren. Ist ganz schön dick. Ist ganz schön groß.
Das ist das meiste, da drin ist wahrscheinlich die Batterie. Es gab ja diese Tile-Tags früher
und andere Bluetooth-Tracker, wo man seine Schlüssel und so suchen konnte halt in der
eigenen Wohnung. Jetzt nicht, wenn man es unterwegs irgendwie verloren hat. Damit man
unterwegs, damit man unterwegs sowas finden kann, braucht das Ding halt zwei Sachen. Das
braucht einen GPS-Empfänger und irgendwie sagen wir mal einen Mobilfunk, eine SIM-Karte
drin oder irgendeine Möglichkeit, mobil auch noch was rauszuschicken. Also entgegen, entgegen
der, das ist im FIND MY NETWORK. Ah, ja Moment. Dann funktioniert es aber nur, wenn irgendjemand
in der Nähe ist, der diese Bluetooth-Dinger empfängt und weitersendet. Ja, ja klar. Ja,
das funktioniert, aber gut, dann muss ich das allgemeiner sagen, du brauchst zum Tracken
zwei Sachen. Du brauchst irgendwas, um deinen Standort bestimmen zu können oder Bescheid
zu sagen, was abgeht und irgendwas, um das weiterzuleiten. Und wenn man es zwar unabhängig
davon macht, dass jetzt keine, dich die ganze Welt mit iPhones vorbeiläuft, gehen wir mal
von aus, von so einer klassischen Sache, du willst irgendwas tracken. Dann brauchst du
einen GPS-Empfänger, dass das Gerät selbst weiß, wo es ist. Also wie gesagt, entgegen,
dass es, worauf ich eigentlich raus will ist, weil das auch in irgendwelchen Filmen und so
immer gemacht wird. Du kannst mit GPS niemand tracken. Damit das funktioniert, brauchst
du zwei Sachen. Du brauchst ein Gerät mit einem GPS-Empfänger, weil GPS ist passiv,
also du kannst GPS nur empfangen. Und dann brauchst du einen Sender da drin, der diese
Daten weiterschickt, wo das Gerät gerade ist. Also du empfängst GPS, rechnest aus, wo du
bist und dann schickst du diese Sachen weiter über Mobilfunk, LoRa, WLAN, was auch immer,
zu jemand, der damit was anfangen kann. Also diese Sache mit Videos teilweise in irgendwelchen
Filmen oder so siehst, ich tracke jemand hier per GPS, Schwachsinn, du kannst über GPS
niemanden tracken. Weiter.
Na geil. Zumal das erinnert mich, das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Gamescom. Da hast
du auch teilweise Sitzdinger und da steht dann sowas wie ich, diese Sitzecke wurde ihnen
präsentiert von Logitech oder sowas. Ja gut, die hatten halt keinen Bock.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, vor was er spricht, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was er sagt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, vor was er spricht, aber da geht es um irgendwelche Corona-Geschichten.
Vyrawarn. Da macht auch jedes Land und jede Firma irgendwie ihren eigenen Krämpel, oder?
Funktionieren die Dinger? Funktionieren diese Atemdinger? Die Dinger können doch eigentlich
nur funktionieren, wenn du schon in so weit Corona-Konzentration drinnen hast, dass du
beim Ausatmen da bist. Wie gut funktionieren die? Weil wenn die wirklich richtig geil funktionieren
würden, dann will ich auch nur noch Atemtests machen und nicht mehr in der Nase bohren.
Was ist besser? Oder was ist genauer? Sich in der Nase bohren oder atmen? Also das wäre
mir tausendfach lieber als in der Nase bohren. Nase bohren ist doch geil, der Chat wieder.
Mag ja sein, aber das in der Nase bohren mit diesen komischen Stäbchen ist nicht geil.
Die Rachenabstriche ist eklig.
Zeus. Zeus ist der Endgegner aus God of War 3. Okay, das war schlecht.
Oder Sus. Kann das sein, dass denen ihre Produktnamen irgendwie ausgehen? Warum, wenn ich doch einfach
Home Assistant verwenden kann? Warum brauche ich noch den 580ten Hub? Übrigens, der hier
macht richtig ordentlich Tabs auf.
Das Ding ist einfach nur da, um viel Geld zu kosten, oder? Ich meine, sieht cool aus.
Sag ich nix dagegen. Das ist aber einfach nur da, um viel Geld zu kosten, oder? Das hat
glaube ich keinen tieferen Sinn. Das ist einfach nur, weil es teuer ist.
Das Dumme ist, das Seitenverhältnis passt halt nicht zu irgendeinem Content, den es so
gibt. Das ist nicht 16 zu 9, das ist eher 9 zu 25 oder sowas. Ich meine, zum Programmieren
wäre es cool, ne? Da brauchst du ja eher vertikalen Platz.
Das war so bizarr, aber bizarr in einem guten Sinne, weil ich einen will. Sie haben auch
ihre Solar Power TV Remotes von letztes Jahr eröffnet. Jetzt kann es von dem Wi-Fi-Signal
in deinem Haus kommen. Ich denke, das ist nur ein Gimmick, um wie wenig Geld du hast.
Ich meine, dass es von der Idee her geht, ist klar, aber man kann ernsthaft nennenswert
Spule oder so, damit man einen Akku laden kann. Vielleicht, wenn man es auf ein Access
einlegt oder so. Jaja, aber dass das reicht, um den Akku zu laden, habe ich irgendwie bewundert
mich. Ja, kannst du, aber das reicht ja bei den meisten Sachen, gerade mal irgendwie
eine LED-Schwach zum Leuchten zu bringen, wenn überhaupt, aber dass man damit ein Akku
laden kann. Ja, weil du brauchst doch, ja Moment, du verwendest die ja auch jeden Tag.
Also mal angenommen, du drückst die Fernbedienung irgendwie 30 Knöpfe am Tag. Und die Frage
ist halt, kann die genug aufladen versus diese 30 Knöpfe drücke? Drück, drück, drücke,
drücks, drücks, drückse. Würde mich interessieren, ob das wirklich funktioniert oder ob man einfach
nur sagt, das geht und es geht, es geht auch, aber halt in einem Umfang, dass es nichts
bringt. Wie viel, na gut, hier, das kann ich dir sagen, es ist die Frage, was diese Fernbedienung
macht. Ja, also wie die Fernbedienung funktioniert. Bluetooth, Wi-Fi, Infrarot, wie auch immer,
aber sagen wir mal, also ein Wi-Fi Signal hat so ungefähr, ich weiß das nur der Spur nach,
weil ich weiß, was ein ESP32 braucht, wenn es WLAN schickt. Also ein ESP82, ein ESP32,
ein ETF, Alter. Verbraucht irgendwie 180 milliampere bei, also 3,3 Volt, 180 milliampere, wenn
es WLAN oder, geht glaube ich hoch bis 240 oder so, milliampere, wenn es WLAN überträgt.
So, Low-Energy-Bluetooth ist sicherlich weniger. Ich weiß nicht, in welchen Regionen sich
das abspielt, vielleicht weiß das einer von euch, ich habe keine Ahnung. Sagen wir mal
irgendwie einen Fünftel davon. Ja, ja ungefähr so wie für einen Tastendruck, ungefähr so
wie für einen Tastendruck. Und ja, keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert. Es würde mich
wirklich interessieren, ob das ordentlich funktioniert. Ich sage euch mal meine Meinung
zu diesen ganzen smarten Kühlschränken. Ein Kühlschrank, ich habe mich da schon öfters
mal drüber ausgelassen, ein Kühlschrank wird nicht smart dadurch, dass er einen LCD-Bildschirm
vorne dran hat. Dabei gibt es jede Menge sinnvolle Anwendungsgebiete, die man machen könnte bei
einem smarten Kühlschrank. Von Barcode-Laser bis Tracking, vom Gewicht her bis Tracking
von den Innereien her. Das ist tatsächlich mal was, wo ich sagen würde, da ist Machine
Learning tatsächlich eine sinnvolle Geschichte, dass man zum Beispiel feststellen könnte,
was fehlt und was nicht. Ablaufdatum-Tracking und sowas in der Richtung. Da könntest du
bestimmt coole Sachen machen. Ja, Unterstützer für irgendwelche RFID-Geschichten, was auch
immer. Also da gibt es Kalorientracker, da gibt es jede Menge Sachen. Aber also ich bezweifle
nicht, dass es einzelne Sachen davon auch gibt in irgendwelchen smarten Kühlschränken.
Aber das meiste, was ich von smarten Kühlschränken gesehen habe bisher, hat mich nicht überzeugt.
Die machen lieber eine Kamera in den Kühlschrank, dass ich von außen in den Kühlschrank reingucken
kann, ohne die Tür aufmachen zu müssen und sowas. Das ist nicht das, was ich mir in einem
smarten Kühlschrank vorstelle. Also die Punkte, die ich jetzt gesagt habe, das ist was, was
für mich tatsächlich ein Mehrwert bei einem smarten Kühlschrank wäre. Ob ich jetzt eine
Kamera im Kühlschrank habe, die ich mir von außen angucken kann oder nicht. Na ja.
Chat, Chat, Chat. Muss ich jetzt kurz was zu sagen. Solange ein Kühlschrank kalt ist und
sich öffnen lässt, ist er für mich, man braucht ihn nicht. Ja, das sehe ich auch prinzipiell
so, aber das ist eigentlich so die Boomer-Meinung schlechthin. Wir sind ja nicht gerade hier,
weil wir uns mit Sachen zufriedengeben, die schon immer so gewesen sind, sondern eigentlich
auch, weil wir uns für neue Technik-Sachen interessieren. Also ich meine, nicht nur Sachen,
die sinnvoll sind. Guck mal, wie viele unsinnige Sachen wir schon gemacht haben hier im Stream.
Ich meine, wer flasht seine Steckdosenleiste? Das ist glaube ich das beste Beispiel dafür.
Niemand von normalen denkenden Menschen 0-15-Normis-Boomer-Leuten würde seine Steckdose flashen. Aber wir
flashen unsere Steckdose und es hat tatsächlich einen Mehrwert. Also es muss nicht alles immer
auf den ersten Blick sinnvoll sein. Alles Noobs, genau. Keine China-Server, genau. So, weiter.
Was ich mich frage, also Chat sagt, was ich mich frage, warum riegeln die ganzen Hersteller
den Staubsauger ab? Ja, der gleiche Grund, warum Ubisoft für ihren komischen NFT-Shit
garantiert einen eigenen Marketplace machen wird und keinen externen, wie es jemand im
Chat geschrieben hat. Weil sie Kontrolle über ihren Graben haben wollen und im Zweifelsfall
dich zwingen möchten, Erweiterungen zu kaufen von ihnen oder ein Abo zu kaufen von ihnen
für Basic-Funktionen, dass ihren Graben weiter funktioniert. Die haben kein Interesse daran,
dass du sowas wie Home Assistant verwendest oder Custom-Firmware, da haben die keinen Bock
drauf. Stell dir noch mal vor, jede 0-15-China-Chinesen-Cam würde einfach RTSP-Streams unterstützen.
Dann würdest du dir den Raspberry Pi hinstellen, dort eine Festplatte anschließen und deine
Kamera-Recordings darauf speichern. Machen sie aber nicht, weil sie dir ein Abo für
ihren Cloud-Storage-Scheiß verkaufen wollen. Und das seh ich nicht ein. Ja, Kampa, dass
das nicht sinnig ist, seh ich auch so. Also preis-leistungstechnisch wirst du mit so einem
smarten Kühlschrank wahrscheinlich kein irgendwie, ja was, Schnäppchen, du wirst da nichts finden
zu aktuell, wo du sagst, preis-leistungsmäßig lohnt sich das. Jaja, da käme ich dir schon
recht. Es ist auch wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil ziemlich unsinnig. Also ich würde mir
auch kein smarten Kühlschrank kaufen, wenn der nicht das macht, was ich vorhin gesagt
hab in dieser Richtung. Einfach nur eine Kamera, die drin ist, ist bescheuert.
Was ist das? Ist das ein Teleskop? Nee, was ist das? Was, was ist das? Ist das eine Kamera
für den, für den, die ich anstatt der Lampe reinstecken kann oder wie oder? Ach, ein Projektor!
Da muss aber ganz schön fest an der Decke sein. Aber warum muss das an der Decke hängen?
Weil man kann, wenn man das haben will, kann man doch einfach auch den Beamer an die Decke
hängen. Also wenn man da wirklich scharf drauf ist. Kaufe ich den Beamer an, hängt
der Beamer an die Decke? Hm, was auch immer. Ja, Hi IQ Chat wieder hier, was ist hier los?
Also bei meinem Kühlschrank war die Steuerung defekt. Die taktete zwei Ventile via PWM an,
um den Kühlmitteldurchfluss der zwei Kältezonen zu regeln. Sitzt jetzt ein ESP32 drin und
ist auch smart. Ja, das ist nice. Hast du das alles selbst rausbekommen oder hast du
im Internet eine Seite gefunden, wo jemand schon mal diesen Kühlschrank analysiert hat?
Gerade wenn es defekt ist, stelle ich mir schwierig vor, rauszubekommen, wie man das
ansteuern muss, wenn du es nicht messen kannst. Okay, tja, Hi IQ. Siehste Leute, da sieht
man es wieder, Prime-Sub steigern einfach den Intelligenzquotient. Es hat schon so viele
Leute gerettet, hier Prime-Sub zu sein. Thanks. Also, you can now buy and view NFTs on Samsung
TV. Okay, weiter. Yeah, you can buy an NFT that costs more than the TV itself. What is
this world coming to? Smart homes have been able to turn on lights to make it seem like
someone's home for a while. But this new device from Home Shadows is taking that up
a notch. It uses 60 LEDs to make a shadow move around, so it looks like someone's home.
Das ist gut. Das find ich ist ne gute Idee. Gerade bei den Amiga Kona Häusern, wo du
dich ja einfach durch die Wand mit ner Axt hauen kannst, weil alles aus Holz ist. Turn
on automatically when it's dark. Das ist ne gute Idee. You can control it with a smart
outlet. It's cool that you can do something like this way easier now. In the 90s, it took
Macaulay Culkin a lot more effort. TP-Link showed up with a really interesting router.
The antennas moved to get the best signal, and time will tell how much this is.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich schwachsinn, ohne es mal ein Test gelesen zu haben. Also
theoretisch könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das was klingt, aber ich meine der Standort
des Routers ändert sich ja nicht. Das heißt, es müsste quasi pro Antenne ein Gerät, also
wenn pro Antenne ein Gerät sich connectet, dann könnte das Gerät tracken. Die Sache
bei WLAN ist aber, dass es halt mehr Geräte pro Antenne sind. Was macht der denn dann?
Hm, keine Ahnung. Vor allem müsste das auch deutlich schneller sein, wenn das für mehr
Geräte geht. Die Ausrichtung wird optimiert, ja gut. Das ist aber nichts, was es laufen
machen müsste. Ich meine, der Router-Standort ändert sich ja nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ne, kauf
ich mir nicht. Es sei denn, die wollen mir einen Sponsoren und ich kann mich dann darüber
auslassen, dann vielleicht, aber ansonsten wüsste ich nicht, was ich, wozu. Ami-Steckdosen,
guckt euch an. Die Ami-Steckdosen sehen immer so traurig aus, guckt euch, ist so richtig
deprimierend. Sad face. Ja, genau so chat, genau so sehen die aus. Sad face.
Pains-Champ-Joke, Alter. Das würde ich gerne mal dem Lockpicking-Lawyer geben, was der
dazu sagt. Der Lockpicking-Lawyer, da wird er wahrscheinlich zwei Minuten, ach zwei Minuten,
25 Sekunden würde er dafür brauchen als das Ding auf. Fake Katze. Brummt das auch? Brummt
das auch? Brummt das auch?
Weird Champ. Du wirst sogar angepustet.
Pains-Champ.
ich hab Hunger, ich muss was essen. Jetzt gucken wir uns dann demnächst an, ich guck
mal, da ich mehr streame in der nächsten Zeit. F**k. Muss was futtern jetzt. Richtig Hunger,
okay Profet. Den hosten wir. The Lost is on, Pupke. Pupke juckt mich so gar nicht. Mein
Manager ist online, Leute, wir hosten meinen Manager jetzt. Easy. Was spielt er denn? Valorant.
Auf gehts. Leute, eine Runde spammen, please. Wenn ihr Primes habt, spammt ihn mal zu, wupp,
spamm, Alter. Raid. Manager FPS, ja. Spammt ihn mal zu. Also Leute, bis denn, wir sehen
uns, was gut, tschüss, bis dann.